Hey fuckers,
happy holidays,
freaks and Geeks and people and players and haters.
This is this episode of Joe Rogan experience is brought to you by stamps.com if
you go to stamps.com and type in the offer code,
J r e in the old school,
the microphone in the upper right hand corner,
you will get a no risk trial plus $110 bonus offer,
including a digital scale and up to $55 a free it to try out stamps.com
stamps.com is an easy,
simple and convenient way to send things through the mail without having to go
to the post office and get thing weighed and find out what your exact postage is
going to be.
They provide you with a scale which you are not doing.
You lose for mushrooms.
No,
no,
don't do it and you take that scale.
You weigh your thing,
you print up the actual us postage on your computer.
Wrangler printer printed up,
slap it on the box.
Post man comes to hand it to him.
Your done no waiting in line.
Nother nonsense.
You have to deal with.
One of the reasons why we're starting this podcast,
ladies.
I didn't,
I forgot it's black Friday.
I don't know why I forgot it's black Friday because I've been talking about it,
but I left.
I'd been give myself enough time and I hit this fucking clog near near the the
mall.
I fucking hate clogs.
I hate the clog at the post office more than any clog because it's just the same
thing.
It's like there's a line everybody has to get to this one woman,
she doesn't want to be there and you didn't want to be there.
It's a mess.
And with stamps.com you can avoid all that shit.
Do it yourself.
Do it at home.
Buy and print,
official US postage using your own computer and printer,
print postage for any letter or package.
The instant you need it.
The mailman picks it up.
It's easy,
it's convenient.
And uh,
we actually have used stamps.com Brian does.
He uses it for desk squad.
Dot TV,
the Kitty cat shirts and he sells the ones that he created.
So all that goes through stamps.com sodas does [inaudible] and Christina Palicki
for the show.
Your mom's house,
their podcast,
they send that stuff all through stamps.com it's awesome.
It works.
Enjoy the fuck out of it.
Use the code word jre and get yourself that $110 bonus offer.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible] Dot com that's o.
N.
I.
T.
We have a big fat black Friday sale.
The biggest sale of the year,
I'm up to $25 $25 25% off the offer closes.
It all ends on December the second at 1159 Pacific standard time pm um,
what does,
what does that mean?
It means it's not just a black Friday sale.
It goes for a few days,
but it's a bad ass sale.
You can save a lot of fucking money on supplements,
fitness equipment,
all of the above.
And if you haven't been to on it for awhile,
we are constantly adding new items,
things that we find that we find a beneficial stuff that we find that's awesome.
New things we have created like the Zombie kettle bells and the primal bells,
which are a gorillas and apes and chimpanzees,
a kettle bells battle robe,
steel maces DVDs that show you how to use these things.
We gots it all,
all of it at [inaudible] Dot Com and if you listened to this podcast and it's
not anywhere near the three days,
nine hours and 27 minutes and 56 seconds until the black Friday sale expires.
As of the time recording of this podcast,
you use the code word jail.
Oh No.
Use a codeword Rogan.
That's it.
You use a codeword Rogan.
You save 10% off.
All right,
we're done.
Greg Fitzsimmons is here.
Let's stop fucking around and let's get serious about things.
Let's talk about life soccer about Greg Fitzsimmons is new comedy special that I
laughed my ass off.
Coming back from the Irvine Improv jazz music,
the Joe Rogan experience,
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
Reg Food Sermons,
my longest running front in comedy.
That's it.
Nobody can break that record.
You can't go back.
Can't possibly
with each other is our longest relationships.
As long as you stay alive.
Right.
We,
uh,
we keep it together.
I'm gone back.
I'm an interview.
Some of the boys.
Are you really?
Yeah.
I'm going back and doing this club laugh.
Boston December five.
Oh No.
That place is really good.
Yeah,
for sure.
Fears.
They're actually this weekend.
Right,
right.
And they just had,
um,
said somebody else.
I'd Proops was there the week before,
but I'm going to do a live podcast on Thursday and I'm going to get some of the
guys out.
Uh,
I'm not sure.
I reached out to a syslog and Gavin and Mike McDonald and Donovan.
Do dil those guys resist that or do they enjoy those conversations?
Like,
because there's a,
there's a bit of remorse in those conversations.
The,
the gray,
we talked to those great comics.
I had a Gavin I want,
so I think is probably our favorite.
Right?
Well,
pretty much honestly,
I think one of the greatest performances I've ever seen is a tie between Gavin
and back in his prime.
Teddy bears rock.
Ah,
do you remember how God damn good.
He was so good.
He made you want to quit.
I know,
like I remember seeing him,
it was an open mic night and teddy went up and I think Jonathan Katz was
actually hosting,
it was one of the times where it was George McDonald,
Jonathan Katz,
remember these still like different people,
different headliners used to host the open mic night and he went up in the
middle and just,
you know,
fuck around for 10 minutes or whatever.
And I wanted a quick common and I was like,
no way.
This swagger.
Yeah.
I mean it was the definition of swagger.
He would walk back and forth on the stage and you know,
when a guy has got that comes to where he's rubbing his thumb against the tips
of his fingers as a kind of like flips his hand around and it was all like he'd
wear the silk suits and he had this horrible orange hair and he would just talk
like a Thespian.
I mean,
he would get to come celebrate with y.
You would have to see it to understand.
Yeah.
And you would really have to see it in the context of 1988 where it was,
I was convinced he was going to be a God damn superstar.
I was convinced.
I was like,
there's no way you're gonna stop this guy from being Billy crystal.
Oh clearly you weren't talking to alcohol and drugs when you said that now I
didn't know cause they stopped him in his tracks.
Yeah,
dead boy did I,
I watched that.
I watched that because I was the beneficiary of it a few times cause like gigs
got canceled because teddy couldn't make it or what have you.
So it went wrong and I got a Gig like glass minute,
I had to stretch twice in a weekend when you know when we were featuring and
they were like,
can you do 30 we'd be like,
yeah.
And our heads were gone.
I got 22 and some crowd work and so I'm up there and I'm supposed to be getting
the light at 27 and a k instead I'm getting a stretch sign and I'm like fuck.
Oh No.
So I go as long.
I do like an extra 12 minutes and I'm dying.
And Teddy comes in and apparently he sits the club owner.
When he came in,
he goes,
yeah,
I'm on.
I'm on a highway.
And uh,
some guys sideswipes me and he says he's,
he takes him out.
Absolutely.
I mean here.
Oh,
did I?
Yeah.
So it's side view.
Mirror is off.
He says the same thing the next night and it's like,
this guy's got a fucking problem.
But,
um,
no,
but I don't,
I,
I don't know if the sadness,
I think it depends.
Like if you still accept that telling jokes for an hour a night for five nights
a week and paying your rent and eating and have a fun,
if you could still accept that that's a good thing in life,
then they're,
they're not sad.
Well,
it certainly is.
It certainly always is.
The sadness comes from more people not knowing how good they were.
Right,
right.
You know,
you want people to know when you hit that high level,
you want people to know.
I mean me swinging was the one that I can certainly say.
Although he was a murderer at the time it was so Boston centric that it was very
difficult for him to have that sort of impact.
Cause he got the shots too.
Yeah.
He got these national
Bosure he did.
He got a few,
a few big spots he did like,
you know one of those comic strip lives or something like that evening at the
Improv type thing.
He got quite a few.
They did some of the young comedian specials.
The Rodney Dangerfield was one of the fairly brothers movies right now.
All the fairly brothers.
Wow.
He's always a cop.
He's,
I've seen him crush like,
like it was like a perfect set.
Like,
like you can't get any better than that.
Yeah.
You just get different.
Was riding laughs just waiting on them and as soon as they fade overhand right
back into the lab
and he had this not give a fuck,
look to him.
He had a big bald spot.
I didn't give a fuck.
His hair was always fucked up.
He couldn't care less.
Right.
He was so like Blue Collar Boston,
that guy went on stage.
You automatically accepted him.
He's the guy that you would just have a beer with.
He's a guy like a,
you might have Steve comes over and has a beer.
Yeah,
bring him over.
Hey Steve,
what's wrong Steve?
Hey,
how are you?
Sit down and just jovial and sucks.
You're right into his personality.
Yeah,
but he could murder.
Somebody was just telling me about him and Oh my God,
it's so funny.
He,
he has an agent in Boston.
I,
I don't know who the guy is,
is some new agents and somebody called and said they wanted to off from a
certain amount of money to do it.
Like you know,
up there,
it's a lot of like,
you know the,
the,
the elks lodge in Mattapoisett or you know,
these gigs that are like fire houses or whatever and they offered him a certain
amount of money and the agent goes,
I'm now,
right now Steve is commanding more money in the marketplace.
It's like commanding in the market,
but a Tuesday night.
What's the marketplace on a Tuesday night?
Exactly.
I think there's no better place to at least start out than Boston because of
that.
Because none of us,
there was no like you're going to make it.
All right.
So making it making,
it was just being a professional comic,
right?
Just figuring out how to get to be a professional.
So in that sense,
yeah,
there's no,
I don't think there'd be any remorse where I'm sure people still packing in to
see guys like Gavin.
Right.
But the world should have known the world should have known.
I feel like it was France Almita capture a little bit and that,
that movie that he did.
Yeah,
he captured it a little.
Well,
he captured what came before us,
which was just before us when it was literally in the formative stages of like,
let's put a microphone in a room and have people talk to audience.
Crazy men do it right.
That's tough guys that don't give a fuck.
Go up and treat the audience like bitches and animals.
And they were animals and it was very testosterone driven.
And like you said,
there was a lot of drugs.
There's a lot of drinking.
And it really was like a,
a certain,
the recipe was your ability to write,
which you only need it for the first year cause then you lock it on that set for
the rest of your life and then the ability to perform and then balls.
Then it was like who onstage has the biggest balls because it was all about can
this guy follow me and trying to bury the guy after you.
Yeah.
And we've talked about that on the set,
but this was their number one flaw was that they didn't change their set.
Right.
They and they,
they were very Boston centric and they never changed her sets.
Right.
But the positive side of that was,
God damn,
they would get those jokes down to a Samurai sword,
sharpness.
They would just hammer those jokes down until they were flawless.
Like Gavin,
the jokes weren't even jokes.
Like if you eat,
some of them you wrote down on paper,
you would go to Sam.
Why that's going to be funny.
Like no,
that's going to be the funniest thing you've seen all day.
So I'm just going to be funny.
Go Watch that.
He just kinda like,
you know,
the way,
the way it comes over.
And he goes,
us,
uh,
we'd like some wine.
And we said,
sure,
and he goes out red or white.
And I,
and I said,
why don't you surprise me?
And he slapped me in the forehead with his balls.
And it does a lot of great joke out of his mouth.
You're fucking dying because the attitude,
you got to see it.
Right.
But you know,
and I think that what we learned from that was number one,
right?
Uh,
but number two,
while you're writing,
do that bit enough times where you do find a way to make it absolutely crush,
you know,
to like to do that doing the same joke again and again and again.
There's no shame in that as long as it's getting better each time until you get
to the point where,
like with Gavin,
where it's just they're,
they're just boiled down perfect little pieces of comedy.
That's the problem with like,
when you release a special to you go,
God damn is this thing,
right?
I don't know if this is done yet.
Now,
you know,
there's that,
that weird feeling of remorse right after you do it.
And the worst is after we record a special,
and then like a month later you have the ultimate tag line that transforms the
bit.
Okay.
Yeah.
Or you realize that there's two sentences in the middle that we're doing
nothing.
And you and you just,
because sometimes they drop a bit and then when I bring it back,
it's a great thing because you forget the shit that was Anessa.
You only remember the good elements all of a sudden it's a stronger Joe.
Yeah.
That's good though.
That's a good way of looking at it.
Like sometimes walk away from it and come back to it.
Yeah.
You gotta be willing to take that fucking initial step,
like it's triple.
It was really funny.
Um,
Wednesday night we did a show at the ice house,
right.
Tripoli went up,
killed it.
But he had a couple of new jokes that it was trying to like for the first time.
And it was just laughing about how going on stage with a new jugs like Bambi
legs,
like you know,
and he's like,
don't worry,
I'm going to work these legs out.
But that's really what it feels like.
Yeah,
we do like,
man,
it's seems pretty funny when I'm going over it in front of my computer,
but fuck,
who knows what's,
it's amazing because sometimes something hits you and try it on stage and it's
actually more comedy than you thought it would be.
Then there's times where like I sit down with a pad and I jot shit ideas and
then at the end of it you go like,
wow,
I thought I had like a rant.
I have maybe a one liner out of all that and it's like,
and you don't know,
and it's not necessarily that the crowd is telling you it's good or not.
You don't know until you're actually putting it out.
If,
if,
if it feels stand up be or if it was just something that was probably good on
paper.
Yeah.
The,
the,
the form of communication that you have with an audience when you're onstage is
impossible to replicate outside of that environment.
It's,
you could try to imagine it in your head where you're alone in front of a
computer,
but your mindset is so ultimately different than it is when you're doing standup
that even when you win the business 25 years,
it's like we have,
it's fucking guesswork,
right?
You're just taking wild guesses.
No,
you're,
the car is idling when you're writing the cars idling you,
you haven't,
you haven't fucking pushed on the gas yet.
That's why it's so important to do both.
It's so important to do both and the both mean you gotta do the actual sit down
writing part two.
There's a lot of guys like to skimp on that.
I'm like,
look,
I know that you write a lot on stage.
I know you're right a lot during the day.
I know,
but I guarantee you if you sat down for x amount of times per week and dedicated
yourself,
just write,
just sit in front of computer,
write a blog,
write something.
Right.
I a
towel man.
To this day,
that fucking guy,
I'll drop in and see him.
And not only is it all new shit,
it's shit from the news from the last three days that he clearly sat down and
wrote,
this isn't like extemporaneous.
Yeah.
Tell doesn't go up and just riff.
He has written that shit
down.
Yeah.
And it's,
no,
no doubt.
Yeah.
He doesn't riff very,
I mean he'll deal with something in the crowd or something.
He'll do crowd work,
but when it comes to material,
he's like beaded it out.
Yeah.
He's got a very unique style.
You know,
he's a,
he's a like a tenacious worker.
I did his showtime show,
which was this ever a show that you would slack off if you are the host,
right.
It's Dave's old porn,
right,
where you sit in front of porn,
you know,
porn tapes from like the 1980s and you do like the mystery science theater thing
to them.
But dude,
he's gotten like,
no tonight Duis and about what worked,
what didn't work and what we should do and what we shouldn't do.
Maybe we should try this and like,
like know enough to know enough to know and he's fucking chain smoking and going
over these notes and sitting down with the are and they're having meetings and
shit.
I'm like,
well,
and then he edited it for ever,
he actually went into his own pocket like a hundred thousand dollars beyond what
they were paying him to edit it.
Whoa.
And then he put together like bonus tracks for a DVD he was going to release,
cause he got ownership of the shell and I swear to God he was still editing it
that until very recently.
So he's gonna release the DVD.
Yeah.
But now he's even further than the hall.
It'll work.
It'll work out.
It's a great show.
He's not getting enough credit right now.
You know,
it tells not getting the credit he deserves right now.
Right here in that like,
you know,
you go to sema clubs and like just half field audiences.
I'm like,
that's ridiculous.
Like
he's got a new show coming out on Kai.
Just spoke to them a couple of days ago.
He's hosting a s like a standup show.
Yeah.
Standup shuts,
there'll be three or four comics per,
I don't know if on their power forward.
Shapiro.
Yeah.
So I think he's doing that next week actually.
He's awesome man.
Yeah.
He's his,
his uh,
skanks for the memories,
right?
One of my all time favorite.
Oh God.
Yeah.
All time favorites.
So I'm fucking this girl doggy style.
I didn't plan it that,
but that plan it that way.
But that's how she passed out anyway.
A couple of mcnuggets later and then it just keeps,
you know,
that joke today would get like,
that would be a part of rape culture,
right?
He'd be on the cover of Salon.
David tell supports rape culture.
Did you see what the writer from the variety set about?
Sarah Silverman?
What did,
she was too dirty and she was trying to be one of the guys and her career would
be further along if she didn't,
if she worked,
didn't work.
So blue.
That's hilarious.
Leigh dumb.
She's the biggest female standup comic in the world.
Where would be further,
well cause TV reviewers feel like,
you know what,
we don't all have the agenda of being billionaires that play theaters.
A lot of us are pretty fucking happy where we are.
It's like what I was just saying about the Boston comedians don't put on them
that they wanted to be international stars.
Like Sarah Silverman does the same kind of material she would do no matter what
the venue,
she works as much as she wants.
She's considered cool.
So she gets roles in movies and TV and she,
I don't know,
she seems to be having a fucking great time
having a great time when she's fucking hilarious.
She's really good.
Like anyone who says it's an Asshole,
right?
Like look,
there's things that people like and there's things that people don't like.
Like you could take me to see a certain type of music that you really enjoy and
I don't get it.
It doesn't mean that it's bad,
it means it's not for me.
But when you break down something that's obviously very successful and very well
loved,
like you're missing the point.
The point,
the reason why it's funny is because she is dirty because she has dirty,
it gets how her fucking mind works right from mine.
Didn't work like that.
The jokes wouldn't be funny,
right?
Like it might not be your thing.
You might be easily offended.
Whatever the fuck it is.
You might have a crab up your ass when you want to write this thing down.
You might have decided to take a,
you know,
a particular snotty approach,
but,
well,
there's a few moving parts when it comes to trying to objectify if something is
good or bad in the arts.
And one is,
is the person,
like you said,
if you're genuinely dirty and you're being dirty,
then it works.
If you're trying to be edgy because you see that that's where the comics do that
doesn't work.
So to me it's about like,
what's your authentic voice?
And number two,
just because somebody is highly commercially successful,
like doesn't mean what they're doing is bad.
That means that it happens to be in sync with what a lot of people like.
Right?
You know,
like,
uh,
I think that uh,
like Aziz Ansari,
he's successful because he literally did focus groups with people to decide
which of his material would work best with 18 to 35 year old.
Like that's the opposite of what good is.
Are you sure he did that?
I read about it in,
if it was a fucking piece in,
I might've been the New York Times.
You sure he wasn't fucking around.
That might be something.
And it was a marketing major in college.
Wow.
That's something that I would say if I was fucking around like,
because it's so the,
I still can't get over whatever do.
Yeah.
Well you know what I did,
I hired a bunch of people to go out and survey people.
This is my point on surveys is always been you never get a good answer with a
survey because you only get the answer for people dumb enough to answer the
survey.
Correct.
Most people like you or I are not going to answer God damn survey on how old the
world is.
Right.
So when you read the Gallup poll,
the recent one that said that some insane number of people,
like 46% of the United States believes in the biblical version of the creation
of earth,
right?
I mean,
I think it's 6,000 years,
Austin 10 that's the,
the the,
the fucking standard.
That's 46% of the Co.
But it's not,
it's not,
that's not true.
It's 46% of people dumb enough to answer your fucking survey.
It's not 46 yet.
It's not,
I don't buy it.
No more than 46% of the people know that.
Whether or not you believe in the Bible,
a biblical God,
more than 46% know that the Bible,
first of all,
it's been translated many,
many times and leave room for error.
And second of all,
they understand the work of science.
You know,
just because you believe in some higher power to make you feel better,
what have you,
it doesn't mean you reject everything.
I think the number,
I don't know if it's as high as 46%,
but does it according to these poles that people that believe that humans and
dinosaurs existed at the same time is inexplicably.
Hi.
Do you know that that was Sarah Palin?
She said that Sarah Pailin had a conversation with a librarian and was Cilla
Alaska.
Well,
she said that on the Internet there was a photograph of,
of human footprint inside of dinosaur footprint.
And the woman,
like the woman like talked about this and Sarah Palin was running for president
or vice president,
whatever.
And she was like,
what?
Pause the pause.
Fuck.
Like this is a woman that got beat away from being the president.
And she,
wow.
She thought that dinosaurs and humans walked together.
And then you see people who are intelligent.
Yeah.
We'll get that pill that down.
Brian claim dinosaurs of people coexist.
Amazing.
Cause it say they're about the librarian.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
Whatever.
Well,
and I think that,
um,
uh,
what's the other one?
I'm not Sarah Palin.
Michele Bachman.
Michele Bachmann's worse.
Well,
her husband's gay,
right.
Is Gay as gay,
as gay,
as gay as the day is beautiful and long and flower smell pretty and butterflies
are beautiful.
That guy's gay.
I let you like,
he can't suck enough dick.
There's no way.
If you could just just give him a free pass.
If you ever got that guy liquored up and put a heart on in front of him,
he would jump on it like Greg Louganis off the top here,
Swan dive on that.
His head would be spinning out of a gainer and he'd still gets some tongue on
the shaft.
He would automatically start salivating to the point where it was like a
waterfall coming out of his mouth,
pouring down his shirt,
just so alive,
a long string.
You wouldn't know where the pool started and the saliva for Dick stocks coming
out of his mouth.
It would literally be like a saliva waterfall and like when,
when not when people have a backyard and they have those really like,
like fancy little rock formations where the water comes down into their pool.
If you're really fancy schmancy,
that was his mouth.
Yeah.
If he,
he would say to a young man,
do you want to go in the hot tub with me?
And the guy would go,
okay,
they'd get in the hot tub and the guy would go,
there's no water in here.
And he'd go,
just wait,
let me see your cock.
That warm and Gooey,
it's comes out 96 degrees.
I'd let them blow me if I knew that I could take down Michelle Bachmann
particular down from what though?
I just because she will be an elected leader.
Joe,
do you really feel that?
I know.
So look,
you just have to see who fox news is trotting out and she is one of the first
pundits they go to for comments on shit.
She is introducing legislation in Congress right now that is actually being
enacted.
So what's the stopper?
Me,
I will suck her husband's deck and release it on the,
on the Internet.
I'll take the hit.
All
we need to do is get them on some ecstasy,
right?
Just get them to realize the folly of his ways.
It's like these people that are like that.
I guarantee you if you got them on some ecstasy and gave him a hug and go
fucking don't worry about it man.
Don't worry about it.
I know who you are.
Just let it go be.
You don't,
don't be gobble,
gobble,
just grabbing them and stuffing them in.
This Steph it in party up.
Dude,
you're already like 60.
He's probably actually probably having a lot of gay sex.
Oh,
there's no doubt he's having a lot of gay sex.
And I think it's similar with a lot of celebrities.
I don't want to mention names like say Oprah,
like her husband,
I believe.
How dare you?
I believe,
um,
I eights I've heard rumors.
He always have to substantiate things like that.
I've heard rumors that he looks extremely gay.
To me.
I would say those rumors automatically.
Um,
if I knew that there was a woman out there or a man out there,
brother whose girlfriend makes $100 billion,
I would say that guy's gay.
Right?
Fucking right out of the gate.
Yeah,
because you're,
you're dick would get so small from being around that much money every day and
it's not yours.
She is so dominant over him and what does that guy do is you make a hundred
grand a year.
I mean,
who knows what the fuck he does.
I think he goes out and does well,
here's,
here's the cash in for doing nothing is the,
he does speeches like they pay him to come in and do motivational speeches.
My God.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
That's hilarious.
Motivational speeches.
Yeah,
whatever.
This is how you find a really which powerful woman and just connect to her.
That's it.
That's the course.
Look,
who knows?
Maybe the guys are really brilliant,
intelligent guy.
Maybe doesn't give a fuck about money.
Maybe it's just enlightened.
No,
it's true.
Actually.
I know dudes that are like that,
that are with really strong women and they are totally cool with it.
They,
they find them and you know,
and chanting and humorous and they go for the ride.
That's fine.
I guess for us we're kind of Alpha males,
so I think it would be difficult for us to picture being in the back seat
maybe and maybe not.
I think there's,
it's really hard when you say that this would work or that would work
generalizing because there's people in my life that on paper I shouldn't like
hmm.
And I fucking love them.
You know what I mean?
This is relationships that I've had with people that despite all the craziness,
I enjoyed the fuck out of my time with them and you know,
and sometimes in a more intense way,
like even though it wasn't like it wasn't anything that had legs like took,
it actually lasts like,
cause after a while you have real relationships where you could actually go on
vacation with someone.
Right.
Do you remember when you first started going vacation with girlfriends and like
three or four days,
then you're like,
oh my God,
I need to jump out of a fucking window now.
Oh,
I had a girl that I faked a phone call.
My friend called me up.
I faked an obligation to get rid of her.
She came to stay with me for the weekend,
just for the weekend and two days in,
she was complaining about everything to the point where it was like there was no
fun to be had.
Everything was just a complaint,
complaining about the music,
complaining about where we're going to go to eat,
complaining about every fucking thing.
And it was,
I was panicking.
My friend called me up and,
and I,
and I go,
hey,
what's up man?
And I go,
oh dude,
I forgot shit.
Fuck,
I got to come get you all.
My God,
I'm so sorry.
Well,
this is my friend Johnny who's quite a slick character.
It was like,
oh,
I can't hit what's going on,
what's going on?
Are you doing over there?
And I go,
Bethany's here.
Shit.
Is that her name?
Damn.
A nice person.
But it was the wrong time for both of us were,
look,
I was a fucking pain in the ass then too,
right?
That was part of the problem.
It's like I will fucking,
that's it too.
I think that when you're a young man,
I think it'd be hard for you to travel with anybody but other young men,
you're just,
you a fucking explore.
You want to really go nuts.
Yeah.
Not only that,
you're dumb.
Yeah.
I was 20,
I was 24,
I think it was maybe 23 at the time.
I was so stupid.
Yeah.
I mean it was so stupid and crazy and it was doing like two years removed from
fighting.
So my brain was hardwired the wrong way.
Like I had to rewire my brain was,
was wired for violent competition and then breaks in between that.
Like that was my whole life.
So going from that to like the,
the like being around girls and relationships and trying to manage those waters
was very confusing for me because I fighting was such like a solitary pursuit.
Right.
I had a,
I used to keep journals,
uh,
up until probably when I was like 23 or something,
but I was dating this girl and we went to Europe together.
Uh,
it was like after Sophomore Year of college that summer she had,
she had studied abroad in,
in Austria for the second semester.
So I saved us some cash and I flew over there and we met in London and we went
to Ireland and we went to France and I was fucking miserable and I was keeping a
journal and I look back at it now and it wasn't her,
it was just that like I just wanted to do my own fucking thing.
I wasn't into negotiating and compromising because at that age you feel like
life is so short,
you don't want to waste a day.
You just feel like whatever the most exciting thing is,
that's what you want to be doing.
And that's often not what comes out in the copper.
This definitely that.
But this is also,
I was just selfish.
Yeah.
I didn't want to do what anybody else.
No,
I think that's what we're both saying.
I mean,
but it wasn't even that I was thinking,
Hey,
life is short.
It wasn't a romantic,
it was like totally egotistical.
You know?
Like if you look back,
like if you had to go back in time and be yourself when you were 23 or 22 years
old,
like what a fucking mess that would be.
Like you'd be like,
ah,
what do I have to deal with?
Yeah.
You know,
you would like look at the relationships that you'd try to manage,
like what the fuck mess you created and that you're just such a different human
now than you were then.
You spend so much energy on relationships back then.
But I'll tell you man,
having like a relationship,
like a special,
like when you were 16 the amount emotionally I grew from like 16 to like 18
which was during the term that I had this girl as a girlfriend,
but she was a very nice person too.
She was the,
she was not in a mean or nasty in any way,
which was really nice as well.
Like I dated some girls after that were,
they were mean and nasty and when it will first time a girl in salt you,
it's like,
it's a weird thing,
you know?
Because like this,
my first girlfriend never would do that.
She was very smart as well and like we would have conversations,
they were interesting conversations,
but there was no manipulation.
There's no weirdness.
And then I dated this girl about a year later that was the opposite.
She was very nice.
She was very pretty unfortunately for her because it gave her this fucking,
this ability to constantly have men around her constantly have people hitting on
her.
But she knew how to fuck with you and like you would see it happen.
She would say something like he was,
he knows always that crooked.
Mm.
And I was just going like,
what?
Like I don't know why.
And then I remember thinking,
what the fuck was that like,
Ooh,
what's going on here?
Yeah.
She would say shit like that.
Like all the time,
you know?
Yeah.
Weird Shit.
And that's where you see bad marriages is when,
when either person in salts,
the other one,
it's like,
unless it's,
you really get that,
that's their stick and they fuck around and bust each other's balls.
Right.
But when you see the guy get a little bit,
you know,
damaged by it,
you just think God,
ah girl,
the girl getting damaged out of it,
he has even more like tension because there's a physical violence worry,
you know,
obviously you know women do violence on men.
I mean I lost a very good friend and Phil Hartman for that very thing.
His wife shot him while he was in his sleep.
That was a horrible relationship and that was a relationship where his ex wife
used to do subtle shit to insult him in front of large groups of people.
Like she would chew chip him down because she was a failed actress and you know,
Phil was a superstar.
It's coming up Saturday night live.
It was constantly a movies and you know,
he was just a will like a deeply loved guy.
And so she would take,
he would take her to parties and she would take that opportunity to insult him
in front of people,
like in real subtle ways like acuity.
We're talking about cars because Phil was like a car nut and he bought a Ferrari
and he was so happy he bought this car.
Like he saved up his money and he's like a big deal for him.
He saved,
there was money made from a couple of movies and he always wanted one of these
things and the way he would talk about it,
like he was a very interesting guy,
very,
very smart,
smoked weed and it would get like real crazy about shit,
like really into things and have these wild conversations and like kid who's a
really,
like he loved things.
He loved becoming a pilot.
Like he became a pilot while we were doing news radio.
And I remember seeing them sitting there like studying due to flee all these
aviation books.
I'm way to add for that,
right?
This guy would study and like his lines,
like when we had a scene,
he would study his lines over and over and over and over.
And he was sitting like a consummate professional.
And this guy.
So when he was talking about this Ferrari,
it was about the Italian engineering and the shape of it and the sound
of the engine.
The whole experience was everything he had just,
and so she goes,
I like trucks.
You know,
my ex boyfriend had a truck,
my boyfriend's back home had trucks.
And so what is he thinking when he,
what do I hear?
What I hear is she's talking about these dudes who are probably truck I pictured
truck,
I've pictured brutish men,
right.
Gorilla fucking her in the back of this truck.
Just throwing some hay down,
ripping her pants off and just fucking send them.
And he's not alone.
Of course,
this isn't fucking,
there's a line of dude ropes,
fucking stirrups on and shit.
But she would say that kind of shit.
Yeah.
You know,
she would always make jokes about him being old or you know,
various jokes about whatever.
You know,
she was trying to chip them down about,
but I'll never forget that.
You know,
I like trucks.
All my ex boyfriend's back home had trucks.
Yeah.
That's just a gross thing to say.
And you get that from your parents.
I mean,
they model it for you.
How you're going to treat your spouse is like,
I see it every fucking time.
I was hanging out with a friend a couple of nights ago and the parents were
around his,
uh,
his inlaws were around and I could see the way they treat each other.
I was like,
Oh yeah,
that's your marriage.
That's how your wife,
Oh,
it's so true.
So my parents,
like,
they really respected each other.
Like they never,
they never did that.
They kicked it around a lot,
but it was so obviously fun what they were doing.
And they really respected each other.
They never took shots in public.
And when they had,
if they had to have a serious discussion and it wasn't yelling,
they would wait until we went to bed.
They go on the other side of the house,
close the door,
and we heard muffled,
you know?
Whereas like some people just Sir fucking argument in front of their kids,
it's like,
well,
that's what your kids are going to do when they grow up.
Yeah.
That's super important,
man.
It's super important to to show them the model of what's possible and if you're
in a bad relationship,
it's just as equally important to get out.
Right.
One of the really important things my mother taught me when I was a little kid
is it getting out of a relationship.
When we were five,
she moved to sing with my grandmother and then we got an apartment.
We moved out of my dad's place because her and my dad were involved in this a
abusive relationship.
So I remember thinking that like,
wow,
like my mom was smart.
She does the right thing when shit goes wrong,
she doesn't just take it,
she has options out.
She figures a way out of it.
Even with two kids,
you know?
So it took a lot of courage to do,
I was going to say balls,
but that's ridiculous.
So you know,
it takes,
it takes like a real sense of action in doing,
right.
Yeah.
I think I,
I,
I think that people always say like,
one thing I've noticed about happy people in life is they all do this.
But I have seen a trend with people that are happier in life and more confident
use their options.
They don't ever feel painted into a corner and like they have to stick with this
job.
They go like,
no,
you know what?
I'll go get a degree.
I want to do this.
And they don't see the obstacles as big as people that are unhappy too.
Well,
as long as you're willing to appreciate the fact that all the energy you put
something might
not immediately translate into this new thing.
Like there's a lot of people that are not willing to accept a dip.
Like that was another thing learned,
learned when,
um,
my mom and my Stepdad got together,
my,
my stepdad was a computer programmer and a had a really good job computer
programming,
but didn't want to do it anymore.
I wanted to become an architect.
So it took a chance,
went back to school,
then became an architect and became successful at that.
So I got to watch that.
Like this isn't what I like to do.
Let's do something else.
And he was happy.
He was happy.
So I get to see those two different,
well one was artistic,
you know,
the computer program I think I guess could be artistic as well,
but he won.
It's more a visual artistic thing,
like wanted to design bill.
I think in computer programming.
Back then it was probably a lot less artistic.
It was probably a lot more just,
you know,
coding just 10 go to 10 go to 20 like all that fucking numerical.
But I think that,
you know,
to see him be happy really is the payoff because that's what you're looking at.
You're looking at,
oh he's happy he did this and you work backwards from that and it encourages
you.
Whereas like get my dad,
this is what he did.
He was on the radio.
He took big fucking shit.
I saw my dad not work for three years,
three years,
and we still,
we didn't get thrown out of our house.
He made it work.
Why wasn't that a situation where your dad had gotten out of favor with some
people in Boston?
Like politically strong?
Yeah,
no,
no.
This is in New York.
In New York.
Yeah.
He was a big radio guy in New York and it was just like,
you know,
program managers change the station director's whatever and they want to bring
in new people and so he got knocked out and it was just a shrinking market am he
was on am radio and it has started to shrink.
Was there a situation where he had gotten into it with some politician or
something?
When my imagining this sink
stern,
stern used to shit on my dad.
Really?
Yeah.
When my,
when stern was coming up,
my dad was like one of the top Djs in New York my whole life.
And so a stern was coming up and my dad used to also host the Jerry Lewis
Telethon.
He was the New York host for it.
You know,
every city has its own and he used to shit on my dad saying he must be a husband
because he's hosting a telethon and he,
but he wouldn't let it go.
Like he just,
he went after guys like gene clave and Ims,
all the guys that were big at the time and that was his emo and that then put
him in that category and then he's surpassed them all.
So my dad,
I don't think it hurt my dad,
although he didn't like stern and my mother hated stern,
but then later he,
my dad died and then stern made a big eulogy about my dad on the air.
Talked about how much he respected him,
how he was like the most well liked guy and the radio and how much you learned
from him.
And so I buried the hatchet.
I was like,
all right.
He was doing,
because my dad always got what he was doing too.
He's like,
yeah,
I don't like the guy,
but you know,
good chess move.
Got Him where he was gone and so,
you know,
it was fucking,
it was weird.
My mom is so upset that I go on stern now still.
Oh yeah.
Irish people.
Correct.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's fascinating man.
Yeah.
So you do,
did you have showbiz aspirations because your dad was in radio and you saw that
business,
you got to see him prosper and be a big time Dj.
Did you,
I don't think the DJ part appeal to me,
but he used to host a lot of charity events and you know,
standup comedy didn't exist then like it did now.
So for him,
I think he would have been a comedian and his day because the,
his favorite thing in the world was to go get up in front of,
you know,
all hallows where he went to high school and raise money by Boston,
shitting on the priests and they'd laugh and he would make fun of this guy in
the crowd.
And he had his stories.
He had his like classic 10 stories he tell.
And it was just like stand up.
That's the thing that I got excited about it and I saw his happiness when he did
it.
And I got obsessed with standup and I used to collect comedy albums and I used
to get up like my daughter just last night on thanksgiving.
She,
uh,
we had a few other girls over the house and my daughter got them all together
and uh,
they rehearsed for like an hour and a half and they put this show together and
it was like acrobatics and shit.
But my daughter and seed it and she did the big welcome to the Thanksgiving show
and it was like so funny.
It was like,
that was me at 10 give me a microphone,
let me MC.
And I was doing that shit and that's,
that's,
I never thought,
like you said before,
like I didn't think about show business.
I didn't think about entertain.
I just thought about stand out.
I want to stand up there and do that.
That energy,
that's it.
And it just led where it led.
It's kind of funny in all the time that's passed that now.
Probably the thing that people know you for from the most is being on stern and
doing a podcast and doing other people's podcasts.
Right.
And doing your own radio show on Sirius on the stern show because it's all gone
like three one 80,
right.
Bally business,
I mean three 16 fact back to you what your dad did,
right.
That's like,
you mean you are known as being a hilarious podcast,
which is essentially the same as the broadcaster.
It's the same thing.
Yeah.
And I didn't want to go into,
I remember growing up is like I don't want to be on radio.
You know,
I didn't,
I didn't get it.
I go in and do my dad's radio show and I thought it was so fucking weird that
there was only a few people and we were talking to each other and were like,
I didn't know who we were talking to.
And then what really sold me on radio was like doing stand up on the road and
going in at,
you know,
six 37 in the morning and Toledo and going in and talking to these shock jocks
and doing four or five in a row on a Thursday morning.
And I started to get into it.
I liked that they were challenging me and that they,
you had to get on,
they're moving bus.
It was like,
you know,
they were gonna fucking bing,
bing,
bing.
And now let's go to Wally,
the weather guy,
and you had to send,
your head is spinning because you just got in on a flight four hours before.
And I liked the challenge of having a like,
you know,
go toe to toe with those guys and then you get to know the guys that you like,
like you know Preston and Steve and Philly,
great guys.
I mean just this,
this guys we both worked with and they're the ones that really shine and we're
going to be in an La,
Kevin and bean.
And uh,
so you go back and then all of a sudden you go like,
wow,
this is a cool way to make your living.
These guys don't have to travel.
They get to kind of do what I'm doing.
But in the same place,
Dale Dudley and crew in Austin,
it's another,
right,
right.
Yeah,
there's a few left,
but not many.
The business is dying.
Bob and Tom,
the business is dying.
It's changing.
Uncle Nasty in Denver.
Yeah,
he's a great guy.
You know,
here's the issue and here's,
here's what's missing.
First of all,
the the medium can only go so far in regular radio censorship.
And the fact that there's commercials,
it sucks,
it ruins the show,
it ruins it.
You,
you can't go an hour without taking a break for a Pepsi ad.
You're fucking up the conversation and you just,
you just are,
they need to figure out a way to sandwich advertisements in the radio.
But I think ultimately the real problem is it radio as a medium,
like one group getting to decide what gets distributed and only a sim,
a small amount of channels.
It's a ridiculous idea.
We all know a hundred guys that were more entertaining than the local radio djs
that we had to deal with a lot of towns,
a lot of regular guys who were like,
maybe they were construction workers,
maybe there were lawyers,
but they were hilarious and interesting to talk to and they wouldn't make a way
better fucking Dj.
And a lot of those guys knew that
two yeah,
they knew it.
So when you came in they would challenge you.
And what I liked was learning how to do radio and then eventually starting to
shift it.
So it kid started out,
they were interviewing me and then I got good enough where all sudden I was
interviewing them and I would,
I,
you'd find the one guy you could shit on,
whoever was in charge,
you go after that guy because his sidekick and the radio and the,
and the weather girl,
they fucking hate this guy because he's a control freak and they always have to
put up with shit.
So when you take him on,
they got your back there laughing at him.
So I,
you start there and then you just start asking him personal questions and by the
end of the interview it's like they come around because they know it's good
radio and you're not,
you're not being fucking directed.
And the going after you with personal questions right away is such a hack tech
because all you're trying to do is make someone insecure.
All you're trying to do is put them back on their heels.
All you're going to,
if you're,
you know,
whatever you're doing,
whatever questions you're asking that or intrusive like I see what you're doing,
all you're trying to do is make someone uncomfortable cause you don't even
really have anything to say.
You don't have enough confidence and you,
your ability to actually be interesting without immediately trying to fuck with
someone.
Especially like the comedian morning DJ thing.
There's a lot of guys are great,
a lot of guys are great to deal with,
but there's a small percentage of Djs that always resent comedians.
And I've heard a million comedian say it and for whatever reason,
whether they think that they could have been us,
so they wanted to do what we do or they resent the fact that you know,
they can't do it,
whatever the fuck it is.
They considered themselves funny,
but there's no actual proof.
They don't get that instant feedback that we get from being on stage all the
time.
So there's like a weird sort of a thing between djs and comedians sometimes.
Yeah.
And sometimes it is that they did the best ones.
I still do it like they're like,
oh yeah,
and I'm hosting the early show Saturday and you're like,
oh fucking,
that's great man.
So you're on my side.
You're a comic and you don't want to throw me under the bus because there is
somewhat of a brotherhood.
It's the guy that quit and now you come in and he sees that you're making more
money than him.
You work in an hour.
And I,
how about the guys who quit become managers?
Really?
Those guys are file,
I don't know.
He's stand up.
So he became mad as a few comedy managers.
Yeah.
There's a few people that quit and then they got into the business.
There's some weird back door.
Yeah.
Other controlling young talent.
Right.
Controlling the future and the dreams.
Sucking it up.
Have you ever met a casting director that was like that?
Like had this thing about controlling the dreams,
trolling your dreams?
You know,
I never,
I would audition for casting directors.
I never got jobs,
so I never got to know them.
I knew them as well as,
yeah,
there was traffic on the four oh five sorry I'm late.
And uh,
do you want me to do that again?
No thanks.
They would have like little pets that they would book booking gigs.
You know,
guys that had gotten close to them.
And there's this one woman that I knew that it was a casting director that was
always banging these guys.
It would audit.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
Casting couch.
Well she threw it on dude's and she was ultra aggressive too.
And she would like,
like my friend was driving somewhere with her and she was like,
look,
we could just stop at my place.
It's only two minutes away.
Ha just kidding.
Actually I'm not.
And the key tries,
he's driving and he's trying to like figure out how to,
you know,
they're supposed to go to this thing together with some function and you know,
she's essentially saying,
look,
I'm two minutes away.
Come and fuck me,
you know,
pulling in my house real quick and then we'll be on our way.
And he's panicking,
you know,
cause he thought this would be a good thing for his career to go with her to
this thing and be close to her and he may never know.
So my casting something and she's literally just slinging her pussy at him and
she's disgusting.
Unfortunately
I liked the story because how many guys at casting directors have done,
you know,
the famous,
can I say so I'm at least glad that there's a woman doing it,
but you know who they love,
you know,
casting directors love who?
Brian Cowen,
man,
he charms the shit out of the room to,
the worst thing is I'd go to an audition and already I'm like,
I just,
I went to acting school for two years in New York and I always felt like I was a
good actor,
but I was a bad audition or I just never,
I never got it how to do it.
And the worst was I'd sign in and I'd look at the signature ahead of me and as
Brian Callen and now I'm sitting there waiting to go in and you can hear the
laughter and the door opens.
And he's got his arm around her and they're meeting for lunch and I was like,
fuck,
and can you validate parking?
Is there any given her three different books to read?
Told her which authors he really appreciates her said about him that his book
maybe one of the most important books ever,
by the way.
And you know Keynesian.
I shift
some of your mutual funds too.
He's hilarious.
But yeah,
he's really good at that auditioning thing.
What's your,
what's your,
well you got,
you've got put into development deals and you didn't like audition for news
radio,
right?
I auditioned for news radio and I auditioned for,
the show is on before too called hardball.
It's actually hilarious and ridiculous,
but I'd only auditioned twice ever for two different things.
Hard Ball,
which I got.
And then news radio,
which I got those,
the only two auditions I've ever went on.
What was your secret?
Just get lucky,
get lucky and be cast into something that it makes sense for me to be cast into.
I didn't like try to do anything.
I was trying to be a comic and then I did MTVs half hour comedy hour and I've
got a development deal.
My manager genius.
Yeah,
with Disney.
My manager is a genius.
He,
he's always been like a really clever guy.
And what he did was he,
he,
I had an offer for a development deal with MTV,
but it was after MTV had gotten ruined by Denis leary leaving.
Like Denis leary became a big star and MTV and then he bolted.
And so MTV was like,
all right,
we're going to lock people in to like serious contracts.
I remember that.
So they,
they had this ridiculous contract,
it was like shit money and it was for a long period of time,
this and their,
their sentiment,
their idea was we create stars.
Like you get on MTV and we're going to create,
we're going to turn you into a star.
And it was like,
wow,
I don't know.
It sounds great.
Like I'd be on MTV.
That sounds great.
I'd be like totally Pauley or something,
but fuck.
And so my manager said he made him,
he took my tape of me on the half hour comedy hour and sent it out to all these
different production companies and said,
this guy's about to sign an exclusive deal.
If you want something,
you have to move within 48 hours.
And so all of a sudden we had all these development deal options and I was in la
in a minute.
It was all because of my manager.
He just exactly what a manager is supposed to do.
He made a movie and he made a move that I would have never done right.
I would have never figured out how to do it.
I never,
I would've never thought of it.
He's just knows the business and he's super clever and he knows when there's
like a little feeding frenzy and he knows how to start one and then I'll send
them on TV.
Like within months.
I might know atom class before you get Bob Nelson,
Bob Nelson,
who was a big guy on Hbo,
he did a special and hour special on Hbo and he was on the Rodney Dangerfield
special,
but he never acting right?
Not well.
I think he did a couple of movies,
but he was huge as a stand right at the time.
He would do the thing with [inaudible] 75 yeah,
it'd be 57 a boxer and do all these characters on stage.
He's hilarious.
Well,
he got clean and sober and yeah,
found God and found,
found God and God found him or however they met and I met on j date,
they became BFFs and he decided to only didn't to me.
Um,
he decided that he was going to use his prayer partner or something like that as
a manager.
So he gave my,
my manager notice,
you know,
that he was going to leave and be managed by this guy.
So my manager flew out to or drove out rather
to Boston to look for new talent.
That's how I met him.
I met him because of this guy.
If it wasn't for Bob Nelson and Jesus,
I would have never met my manager.
So Jesus brought me to my manager,
who I think is the most important person I've ever met as far as like my career,
Jeff Sossman for sure.
And he's,
he's new one.
We've been together since I was like 22 or something like,
that's amazing.
Yeah,
we didn't get it from the rare for people not as show business.
The thing is is it's a very tenuous relationship with management.
Like I remember my first manager,
I really thought I bought into the whole like we're best France,
which didn't organically happen about it.
Fact,
it never really did happen,
but I believed it did.
And so to actually strike a real friendship with a manager,
I warn people off of it.
I tell young comics,
look,
remember you,
all your representation agents,
managers,
they believe in you and that's amazing and you should be really thankful for
that.
You know,
like they're going to wake up every day and be the only other person thinking,
I want Greg Fitzsimmons his career to go better so that that's great.
But remember that they're going to drop you if you're not making the,
you know,
at the end of the day they're working at a job and they got to show some profits
at the end of the year,
so don't get too invested in the friendship thing.
But with you guys over so many years it,
it becomes a friendship that is probably what like equal to the business
relationship
more than,
because if our business relationship ended,
our friendship would never happen.
Right.
Our business relationship would never end either.
I mean,
I told them when we first started working together,
I just knew,
you know,
there's certain things in life you just know he's,
he's not just a,
he says,
first of all,
he's fucking hilarious.
He's without a doubt the funniest manager of all time.
He's a hilarious guy,
never thought about doing standup,
but he says ridiculously funny shit all the time and he loves making comics
laugh,
so catch it,
you know,
off your guard and say something like ridiculous and hilarious.
He's just,
he understands comedy like in and out.
He's also brutally honest.
Like he was fucking brutally honest with me when I sucked.
He was brutal when it first started out and he saw my potential.
He was brutally honest with me that he was brutally honest with me when he told
me he thought I was playing pool too much and I wasn't doing enough stand up.
Yeah.
We've been friends,
like from the first time when we first started becoming a manager,
he also became my friend.
So if I had to pick 20 people,
20 people,
we're all gonna die and 20 people are going to go off into space and live
forever.
He's coming with my fingers too.
Wow.
Yeah.
I so I agree with you though.
For the most part,
like my agents please the gum that go,
do they listen to the Pi?
This is this.
I love them.
I love my current agent.
She's awesome.
But my,
what happened with me was a series of betrayals and you know,
bad deals and people,
you know,
just a lot of stupid shit has happened with agents.
Not a single stupid shit has ever happened with my manager and the position I
think a good manager has is a good manager is looking out for your career in
total for the long haul and Susman.
One of the things he always gives me great advice as far as do what you actually
want to do.
Forget about how much this is paying you.
Forget about how this would pay you more.
I'm going to inform you this is how much it's getting.
You're going to get paid this much more or this is this,
this is that,
but what do you want to do?
Let's let's look at the your life and your career as a whole.
Like what would you want to do right
now?
Do you want to be in computers?
You want to be an arcade,
do what you want to do.
And he's always had that advice,
right?
It's never been like go specifically for this amount of money.
And there was some times where it was like,
well,
I don't know what to do.
Like fear factor was a perfect example.
Like,
she's,
I don't know,
do I really want to host a fucking game show?
They sick dogs on people?
Like,
I mean,
he's like,
well,
you know,
you've got to think about this.
You're ultimately going to be the one doing it.
I mean,
here they're offering me this big show and he's saying,
you know,
don't do it if you don't want to do it,
but if you want to do it,
this is the show.
Right.
You know,
it's like a smart way to handle a career and he's,
his position has always been the managers there for the long haul.
The agents,
they're great,
but they're a tool.
They're a,
there a way that you connect to the buyer there a way you connect to the person
who wants to do,
you want to show in nature,
they're going to drop you faster if you're not making money because they
represent way more people.
Yeah.
They're like a stock market.
This is not,
there's,
I mean there's some humanity involved,
but like when the car was men,
Sia thing went down.
My agent dumped me.
I had an agent dumped me before that.
You know,
there's a lot of,
like,
there's a lot of dumping going on.
There was a lot of leg abandoning and this ain't going to work.
Or you know,
phone calls after a bad audition,
you better shape up,
fuck you fucking end and send this,
you know,
those weird ones,
we were like,
this is just weirdness.
Right,
right.
You know,
I went through a lot of agents in my life and I've been really lucky.
I got one that,
uh,
not just one,
but like the agency I'm with,
there's the one,
there's kind of like the big guy and then there's the guy that does like day to
day more stuff,
who's also a big guy.
But like I've been there so long that they've both moved up but extremely loyal
to me and I respect them and you know,
I feel like they give me a good shake.
But one agent that I left was my fault.
I was at,
it was at Gersh,
I was at courage where I was happy and I,
you know,
and I,
I like,
I like some people over there,
but I was the lonely during pilot season and there was this black agent named
Laurie and a and then sort of name.
And then there was a,
a black,
uh,
assistant for somebody.
Can they just be people?
What the blacks someday these people,
these people that you're mentioning that you keep calling black people.
No,
but it's,
it's important for the story.
It's more for the story.
So the other girl's name was like Danielle.
Okay.
And so I'm in there one day and this bag in pilot season where there wasn't
email and shit.
So when you had auditions,
they either had to FedEx a script to your house or you had to drive to your
agent's office and pick up some scripts.
So it was back in the day where Joe,
if I could tell you how many fucking auditions I went in on in my life,
I am so grateful to the agents that believed in me.
I mean,
I had so many swings at the,
and it was not meant to be,
so I'm in there.
I got to fucking arm full of scripts for auditions.
I'm going in,
it's pilot season and I'm walking out and I see a black woman and I go,
Hey,
Danielle.
And she goes,
it's Lori who's the big agent.
And I went,
oh,
okay.
And on the ride home,
I call my age and I'm like,
yeah,
uh,
I think I have to find them.
Then I call my manager.
I said,
I think I got to find other agencies.
Because you don't get past that.
Yeah,
that,
well,
that's just a mistake.
Why do people get so upset if you call it?
I don't know if they got upset.
I just PR I projected it most likely they probably got upset.
People get upset if you don't say the right noise with your mouth.
That represents them.
Right.
They're very attached to,
especially when it's a name that's not even original.
It's not like your,
your name is Kwan Aila,
March and Alda.
Some shit.
I do have a hard time telling black people apart though.
No,
I'm not kidding you
there are so good though.
It telling Asians apart and I'm really good at your routine.
You did it successfully on the fly,
on your new special.
I thought it was hilarious because I was driving home.
I was like,
this motherfucker did it a special,
I do it every night.
You have this weird thing where you could tell like who's Cambodian?
Who's Filipino,
who's,
you're probably like 80% on
93 I was in Edmonton last week and I called out.
There were four girls in the audience and I guessed them in order.
I said,
you are Filipino,
which is kind of a slam dunk because a lot of Filipinos in that area.
I do my research and then I called out.
One woman was Korean and then another woman said she was Asian.
I said,
you're Indian?
She said,
yes,
I actually am Indian and the last one I said you're half white and the other
half is Japanese.
How can for for for how can you tell Greg is there?
I could tell the Japanese is usually like they have like a look that looks
Japanese,
Japanese.
There,
the palace of the Asian women and their faces are a little bit puffy,
but in proportion,
right.
If I can see their feet,
it's over.
I got it.
But,
but no Vietnamese are very petite,
very angular and Puffy Lips.
Filipinas are the largest breast of the Asian women.
Chinese really do have flatter faces.
It's that simple.
Koreans are a larger version of the Chinese,
uh,
Cambodians have a Tan.
I mean,
did you see the article about the woman in China who had had like $100,000 where
the prostate surgery met a man and then the husband when the children came out
was suing because he thought that she had had sex with him.
The man,
like there was no way the kids could be this ugly if they were from his
beautiful wife.
And then he found out that his wife had had all this plastic surgery and he won.
He Won.
Oh Shit.
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
He won because his wife was too ugly,
which just think about the nose job thing.
Pulled it up,
Brian.
Brian,
I mean,
you have kids that come out with giant fucking noses and your wife doesn't and
you don't.
Yes.
That happens.
Yeah.
That happens a lot in Newton where I grew up.
That's the nose jab capital.
These,
cause there's a lot of nose jobs man.
And young kids too.
It's really sad.
You know when you see a young kid getting their face cut open,
like,
um,
there's a,
there's a kid in my neighborhood that's 16.
It just got a nose job.
No,
that's apparently like in,
in Hollywood.
It's,
that's a big like sweet 16 present for girls.
Yeah.
No,
this is the evil man says it's a hoax.
Oh,
it's a hoax.
Yeah.
God Damn.
At the Telegraph.
What,
what day was that?
Uh,
this was,
it's a whore works Harkes November 9th,
2013.
Oh,
okay.
So that must be the way,
it's hard to tell.
No,
look man,
if I,
if a girl has plastic surgery,
you kind of can tell.
I don't know if she had that much plastic surgery.
The guy's got to be a moron to think that.
Yeah,
it didn't.
That's her natural face that you could actually do.
That didn't make sense.
You could actually sue something for that.
Yeah.
It looks like it was a marketing thing for our plastic surgery company.
Wow,
that's smart.
Yeah,
because it's amazing what they can do.
Have you seen what a lot of these Asian women are doing with her eyes?
No,
especially Korean.
In South Korea apparently is the plastic surgeon,
surgery capital of the world,
and a lot of South Korean women are getting plastic surgery,
facial work done,
and they get this weird thing done to their eyes were their eyes look enormous.
They turn their eyes into agent from Asian eyes is anime eyes.
It's very odd.
Post some pictures of it up Brian.
So it's very weird and it's like it's very prevalent.
Korean sat very,
they have a,
how do you say it?
Without sounding offensive.
They have thinner eyes.
Then eyes.
Well,
they're getting,
that shit changed and they're also getting their jaws changed.
His girls were getting,
their jaws were always into that for women broken and then reset to make a more
appeasing shape.
They're all kinds of really nutty shit.
They're doing to their faces,
Chin implants.
A lot of women are getting these chin implants.
If they have a weak chin,
they put a chin implant in to strengthen their,
it's so fucking strange man.
They put like a plastic Chin on you
and it seems like the direction should always be whatever you're planning on
doing.
And my Chin do half of that.
Whatever you're giving me for tits,
do half a like you wouldn't be able to tell there were breast implants if they
didn't have to go double d every time.
Put in some fucking solid C Cup.
Oops.
Yeah.
Well you know,
or don't do anything or don't do anything.
But if you're gonna do it,
just show restraint.
The problem with it is man,
just like Anorexia or what bodybuilders get,
it's,
you don't see yourself anymore.
You start getting like so micro that you miss the macro.
You miss the no,
no girls dude,
pull up girls,
girls,
surgery eyes.
There's some insane photos.
Oh yeah,
look at that.
What the fuck her chin look like?
It was changed.
There's some better ones.
There's some ones,
women's eyes that are like really strange.
Yeah.
Look at this guy though.
Before he had,
you know,
the obvious slant,
but now it's actually all it looks better.
It looks better.
No,
I think Brian was saying the opposite.
Look at the girl above that one and the all above that one.
That one.
Yeah.
I think that looks better.
I like the anime eyes.
Yeah,
like the anime eyes.
She's wearing makeup as well.
Yeah.
That's the thing with before,
after pictures,
it's always like they,
you know,
they're taking them at a different angle.
Yeah.
They do different levels.
Different women.
I know.
Yeah.
They did our job,
but the job,
yeah.
Look what they did where they draw different.
Yah.
She had like a,
an Okie jaw.
Remember that bass pro wrestler that fought Muhammad Ali and Tonio Gnocchi.
This difference.
Whoa.
Yeah,
that's exactly right.
And the first one.
Yeah.
Well they,
they crack that open.
I had a friend who had his underbite fixed.
He had a,
he was born with a ridiculous underbite and then when he was 21 he had it fixed
and then Bam,
all of a sudden became this really handsome man.
Whereas up until he was like 20 or 21 he was like,
a freak kind of makes you look dumb.
The underbite well,
you know it's a bad gene thing.
You look at it and go,
that's not right.
You know,
it's like eyes that are too close together.
A jaw.
That's two lights.
Like the whole Divinci code that there's this
Nachi.
What's that?
FIBONACCI?
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
It's a FIBONACCI sequence.
It's like the same thing that you see in nautilus shells and then sunflower
seeds.
The,
the mathematical code,
like the length of triangulation of the size of your note,
like all the,
all your features.
They all fit the same way a pine cone fits.
Like there's,
there's a mathematical proportion to people's faces.
So when you fuck with things and change them,
like a lot of times it's weird,
like,
especially like the big nose thing.
Like when people like all of a sudden don't have a big nose anymore.
You're like,
why is your head so long?
Then like,
where's your nose?
I know some comedians that should do reverse plastic surgery cause they're too
good looking.
They should add a giant nose and shaved the top of their head off.
Well definitely guys don't want to fucking hear good looking guys.
Tell them jokes while their girlfriends laughing.
No lot of guys know that shit.
They do not.
That's why the good looking guys end up going so fucking dark.
Like you look at like,
uh,
what's his name?
Um,
uh,
Jessel neck.
Like he's so good looking that he has to become gross.
Really Gross I think to,
to sort of get the guys back.
I wouldn't ever gone with him.
I would've gone with a homeboy from Dane Cook show.
Uh,
Gary Goldman,
Goldman.
It's beautiful.
Matte right.
Giant too big handsome guy played football for BC.
He shoots it's perfect features,
beautiful hair.
I would go with Gary Goldman.
I'm not listening.
If I'm,
I'm date not happy.
This guy's up there.
Yucking it up.
This big beautiful man.
Yeah.
And not only that,
but it looks big enough that he could kick my ass.
That bothers me.
All this stuff is huge.
Yeah,
well it's the,
you know,
the thing,
the,
the immediate like,
I don't like that,
which is one of the big advantages of a guy like Joey Diaz.
Joey Diaz goes on stage and it's a human cartoon,
like right away,
he's the Ron Jeremy of comedy and a lot of ways and for people don't know what
you're saying.
You know.
Well,
this one of the appeals of Ron Jeremy,
right.
He is,
uh,
not challenging you.
You could walk in the room,
tap out Ron Jeremy and watch a smile creep on that girls face in the porn scene.
She would,
she'd rather be fucking
most likely.
Right.
Except Ron Jeremy's got enormous cock.
How much do women care about the enormous cock thing?
Is it overrated?
This guy doing a documentary on it?
Yeah.
I remember the guy that was a embarrassed by his girlfriend on the jumbo tron.
There was a guy who he on live TV,
he proposed to his girlfriend.
Oh,
I've heard about the stories and he got rejected.
She said No.
Well,
he's making a documentary on his penis size because the reason why she rejected
him is because his penis is too small.
Pull that up.
That's he's so he's working on this documentary now as an La guy and he's just
being real open about his dick size.
It's like,
you know,
if,
if average is five and a half inches,
I'm below average.
That's what he's saying.
So it's,
you know,
really does have legitimately have a small Dick and he's doing all these things
like you attached a weight to it.
He tries to stretch his dick out to it,
into all these different things
they show you.
Talk about a market that for advertising,
man,
nobody,
it's like hair loss and small penis.
That's all.
Because every guy,
I have a good size.
I have a big penis.
How big?
Every woman I've slept with,
his commented on it.
They love it.
They,
I don't know if they love it,
but some of them don't like it.
It's too big girth also or no,
it's proportional,
but it's,
um,
it's something that has been commented on and my brother is a matter of fact,
uh,
women that he slept with have said to me that he also has a very big team,
very happy with your penis.
Extremely happy with,
so you wouldn't be a good guy to talk to for this guy if you wanted to.
Now,
if he talked to me,
I think he'd feel like you feel when Gary Gulman is onstage
seven inches.
No,
I don't have a huge cock.
Don't get me wrong.
I'm not saying huge cock.
I'm saying it's a really,
I think women are surprised him 150 pounds.
I think they're surprised at the size of it.
And I think that,
um,
it's one of the few things about me physically that's not repulsive to me.
I hate that I'm bald.
I hate that I'm skinny and that I'm pale.
I hate everything about my body,
but I'm very happy with my penis.
It's funny because the stuff that they use to market for big Dicks,
like all bullshit,
but the stuff that they use for hair,
there's some stuff that works,
like Propecia works and Rogaine works,
but the Dick thing,
nothing yet.
There's still things out.
There are still things out there for the hope.
Just the fucking vague hope that maybe something,
my point is does it really matter?
Like do,
does the average woman really care about a dick being bigger or smaller?
Isn't it really about like how is the foreplay?
How's the motion?
How's like what are you doing with your hands?
Oh,
10,000,004 days.
A lot of black dudes goofing on him.
But did people know at that moment it was about as Dick?
Oh yeah.
No,
no,
no.
That was it.
She didn't think that we were right for each other was because my penis was a
little too small for her.
What Patrick and I had his first experience in the bedroom.
That's her member.
Mine is different.
Girls were just making out.
Sex is a very important part of relations.
Anybody says the size doesn't matter.
I don't think that size matters,
that guys with small Dicks,
let's say that I think that the men of the world deserve an answer to this
question.
And so I'm going to find it.
That's sad apartment,
that little Dick apartment.
So great.
Probably just said,
hold on,
let us go.
What the fuck?
This looks interesting touch.
Yeah,
but do you want it?
Oh yeah.
Wow.
The male body was not subject to a critical gaze.
And nowadays everybody wants to have a big penis in as like a gift.
I don't want this on my Netflix history though.
Don't be scared.
You get a big Dick.
Let it swing someone constantly.
Come on,
take a look.
Well,
you know Colin Quinn heard about it because I'd slept with a few female
comedians,
did it,
talked about it.
And so there was a room.
So Colin Quinn on tough crowd said,
I,
I want to see it after the show.
We're in the green room and I,
I whipped it out,
which you can say when it's big enough,
you'd say whipped it out.
And uh,
he was there with this,
uh,
with a few people.
And one was this black woman and she went,
oh
well that says it right there.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
This,
uh,
this is an interesting subject for a documentary,
but when a guy says it's something,
does it matter to a girl?
He's being a fucking idiot.
Period.
You don't know what matters to a girl.
You don't even understand what it's like in any way,
shape or form to be a woman.
So pretending that you know what a woman wants sexually,
that it doesn't matter.
It might be the most important thing is actually,
how about that?
Yeah,
evolutionarily it makes sense.
I'm just wondering,
because the size of a woman's vagina to me doesn't,
I?
I can't.
I remember walking away going like,
like guys go,
oh,
she had such a tight pussy.
Like I don't remember ever really that being a giant factor.
Like I remember being like with young girls who were like,
you know,
1718 and definitely it was small.
Right?
But just stop and think about what you've already said.
You've already said you have very nice sized penis.
So for you it wouldn't have as much of an impact as a guy who's got a needle.
Dick,
a guy having a needle,
dick dating a girl with a tight pussy is a huge plus.
Right?
For you it's like your Dick is pretty good size.
It doesn't matter.
Yeah.
You know,
but to the girl,
I think for a lot of girls in matters a lot.
It's not,
it sucks guys who have little Dicks,
I'm sorry it's a Shitty fucking roll of the dice,
but it's the way of life
isn't it?
Like if you look like a bat,
like I don't know a lot about basketball players,
but I know there's some really small guys and they learned to drive to the hoop
better and they steal a lot of balls on defense.
You learn how to make it up and the rest of your game you get that.
There's nothing keeping that guy with a big giant Ron Jeremy Dick from being
good at eating pussy and being a great personality and being really sensitive
and supportive.
Boyfriend's a star.
No it's not.
It doesn't matter like just because you have a lot of get up and go doesn't mean
that a guy who also has natural talent and physical attributes doesn't also have
a lot to get it right.
It's like the difference between a martial arts champion and a guy who really
will never be fighting for the title.
It's like there's certain guys that just lack the physical advantages that the
guys at the version,
yeah,
but the guy who didn't have the natural advantages,
he lives in a bad neighborhood and needs to kick ass or he's going to get
killed.
I have a small Dick has to get good foreplay down,
learned about finger in that anus.
Anderson Silva can be living in a castle.
It's still put,
get out of his Rolls Royce and kicked the shit out of you.
Right.
There's certain guys that can just do that because they have natural physical
advantages.
They also have talent and they also have an incredible work ethic and
intelligence.
On top of that,
you would assume that someone with a lot of natural talent doesn't work as hard
to never get as good.
And that is often the case.
But just because you're a hard worker,
it doesn't mean you're guaranteed success.
There's certain realities about the physical attributes.
And a guy with a little dick is never gonna be able to fuck.
Like Ron Jeremy,
Ron Jeremy's got a hog and his pants and he pulled that's fucking nine inch fat
cock and you're like,
Holy Shit,
me,
his dick is huge.
And he goes down on them for a long time.
He's an animal.
But,
but what I'm saying is there's nothing to stop a guy who's built like that from
also being a really nice guy.
Like,
so for a guy like this,
he said,
I don't think size matters.
Listen Dude,
that's a part of life.
Okay.
Just like the shape of your face matters.
Just like an underbite matters.
It's a weird thing.
Should it be the only thing?
Absolutely not.
No.
You can still be the,
you can overshadow that.
Hopefully with cunnilingus and with,
uh,
talking dirty eye contact.
I mean there's a lot of things during lovemaking that are factors in lovemaking.
You ain't even say fucking you went deep cause I'm talking about something to
men.
I think that like I'm sure personality,
you know guys that after the sex,
like I'm ashamed based Irishmen.
Every time I would get laid I would fucking get dressed as soon as possible and
make an excuse to leave.
There's a guy who can hang around and cuddle that that means something.
Sure.
And there's also something in like the way two people connect.
Like there's certain girls like they might be exactly as good looking.
Like if you looked at them like wow,
she's very pretty and she's very pretty like they're equal.
But one girl just has a way of talking,
just has a way of being,
just has a charm or a wit and makes you just want to fuck so bad.
And when you're with her,
it's so exciting and satisfying and crazy.
And the other girl,
you might as well just be jerking off into the abyss.
It's just like you're just wasting your time and it's nonsense and she can be
beautiful.
She could be beautiful with a perfect body.
It's gets boring after a while.
If you're not connecting with someone,
ultimately it gets boring.
I was in Denmark,
um,
I was like 18,
and I was over there and I,
I lived there for two months and there was this girl who was like a supermodel.
And believe it or not,
having dark hair in Denmark is a big deal.
Everybody's blonde and blue eyed.
And if you look different,
like black guys,
the guys in the military that live in Scandinavia fucking tear it up.
The chicks love it.
And I'm up there and just because I have dark hair,
I'm actually doing better than I normally would.
I was getting better quality women.
So I was with this girl who was really beautiful and uh,
and I had sex with her and going back to my journals that I would keep.
And I wrote in my journal that I had sex with savant,
know whatever the fuck her name was.
And uh,
and I was so surprised.
It was kind of boring.
She didn't really,
she just wasn't that exciting.
And so she,
I was staying at her friend's house.
Her friend read my journal and told her and then she,
we hooked up again,
which I didn't think we would,
it was like a onetime whatever.
And then she really came after me and fuck me again.
Hard.
And then at the end she goes,
so was that better than the first time I go,
what are you talking about?
She was like in your journal the first time.
So she had a point to prove.
That's hilarious.
I yelped I give her bad Yelp came back swinging.
How long before this
Yelp for personalities,
like a slug of floating star above people's heads.
You see what?
Google glass when you curse her over them when you meet him on the street and
he's coming for sure.
Just the sum total of the people that you interact with in your daily life.
The only people that actually get access to this,
you know,
like a thing when you allow people to rate you.
Well,
there's a thing now called,
um,
my son does it called ask.
Yeah.
And it's very similar to that.
People ask each other questions like he,
they'll ask him,
who's the prettiest girl in seventh grade or do you like so and so?
And then the people get,
they get rated on that and how they,
how they respond.
Right,
right.
Problem with that is you,
do you want to be with someone who agrees with you on everything?
Do you want to be with someone who's like,
if you're,
if you're meeting someone,
I think one of the cool things about relationships is meeting someone who is
nothing like you.
Nothing in like what they like,
like,
and you can be like,
you really liked that,
you know,
like just getting to know something and knowing that just because you don't like
the same things,
you could still like each other.
I enjoy people that like music,
but I think it's fucking terrible.
Like I have a gang of friends that love the grateful dead.
I've never got it.
I don't get,
I'm probably never will be another one.
There you go.
Exactly.
I love you.
I love that.
And I know a lot of guys that did a hate Bruce Springsteen.
And I just sense it doesn't make
any sense if you,
if you listen to born to run,
born to run is a fucking masterpiece.
It's a masterpiece.
[inaudible] album is a masterpiece,
the whole opposite masterpiece.
But the dude is,
he,
he's undeniable,
undeniably talented.
Just a little too good looking.
That's the problem.
Are you serious?
Yeah.
That's why the underbite listen,
he's still very beautiful in his own little caricature he way in a blue collar
way.
It doesn't get any better than that.
A lot of guys don't like that.
Your girls want to fuck.
It's probably true that and,
and also he was poetic,
you know,
I mean,
you look at the words to jungle land,
Oh,
jungle lands,
one of the best of all time,
greatest songs of all time,
you know,
and it's like,
uh,
and in the quick,
quick at the moment
and reach for their guns and shot and make it final stage.
He gets older.
He's still slinging debt.
Yeah.
Oh,
brilliant disguise.
Remember he gotten that divorce with a beautiful woman.
You got a divorce.
And then he wrote a brilliant disguise.
That's a God damn home run of a song.
Right.
Fuck that song's good.
And after nine 11,
the rising,
he wrote that album and it was like the most movie was to me the most authentic.
And he actually had written a lot of it before nine 11,
but in the context of it coming out then it was the most authentic response
artistically that I saw tonight.
11.
It was an inspirational and they played it,
uh,
at,
at God was at,
at his inauguration,
I think it was at Obama's inauguration.
They had a choir come out and sing the rising.
And I mean you talk about my son,
me and my wife was sitting there and my,
my son's like,
why are you guys crying?
And you're like,
and we're like,
you can't explain to him that the black president is a big deal cause he's only
seen one get elected.
Right.
And,
and you know,
and you like,
someday you're going to understand what this moment means and how perfect this
fucking song is right now.
But yeah,
I think that that not getting people's tastes the same.
Doesn't matter.
It's attitude.
You'll never get attitude across on the Internet.
And when you meet somebody and you see them roll their eyes at somebody,
you also think is corny.
Sometimes that's the spark.
Oh yes.
Well the cornea is a different thing.
I mean,
it's just like things that I like that are fucking terrible.
I know they're terrible,
but I enjoy them.
Yeah.
You know,
I go,
I'll end Jay legitimately enjoy an episode of Walker,
Texas Ranger.
I will enjoy it.
I don't expect anybody else to sit there and watch it with me.
You know?
It's like,
but I will enjoy it.
And you can't tell me that this music that I like,
that people will say socks.
I like some Toby Keith songs.
I don't give a fuck.
You like some big hair bands too,
right?
Bon Jovi,
one direction.
Look a little Bon Jovi.
You try to be funny.
Um,
I like,
um,
you know all like Whitesnake Whitesnake right,
but so what,
so what I like shut stuff that you might think sucks.
Have you ever seen a bear,
a band called a,
is it hair nation?
No.
What does that look like?
A spoon.
It's the one,
it's a spoof band in Hollywood,
but they've got the sickest musician,
Harris Steel Panther.
No,
not steel.
Panther is another one now.
It's not new.
They've been around,
they play Tuesday nights at a,
at of the big rock clubs and I saw him in Vegas.
You would love them because it's like the best um,
def Leppard songs.
Whitesnake poison light.
But the song you really want to fucking hear,
I'm sure it's not steel panther ups,
not Steel Panther.
I know that's the same genre,
but these guys are um,
God,
it's not school of rock.
It's like,
I'll think of it if you want to put it on your website later,
but I'm still panthers fucking awesome cause I didn't like the,
I didn't light hair,
bad hair metal at all when I first heard it.
Then I saw these guys and I had to go back and now I start listening sometimes
to a hair nation,
I think is the name of the station on Sirius.
The plays that music and I had to go back and start going,
oh,
I missed some shit.
I missed some good shit.
That's fine.
Yeah.
Um,
find it at Bri.
Brian,
find this band for me.
Spending look like an asshole.
Use Two hands.
Momma yelling at Brian.
He's your guy.
She's helps more people need to yell at them.
Um,
yeah.
I saw Steel Panther in Vegas at the uh,
at the House of Blues.
They're amazing.
Yeah.
Incredible.
His fuckin Ozzy Osborne impression is insane.
You feel like you're actually seeing Ozzie,
I mean he moves like Ozzie sings like Ozzy.
Sounds like Ozzy.
The musicians are bad ass
metal shop.
Metal shop.
Hmm.
Alright.
School,
School of metal.
Metal School,
metal school.
Maybe it is metal shop and you're fucking this whole show up.
No.
Trying to find this thing.
Fuck.
I hate when I do this on a podcast you want to do in life.
It makes me think of my memory's going.
There's only so many things you can store.
Do you find that as you get older you have less room for shit?
Yeah,
without a doubt.
It's very frustrating because I'm getting to the point where,
you know,
I used to just write on shows and now I'm in the position where like I just,
I ran two shows this fall.
This is where,
and I need my memory more than ever before and it's,
it's less than what it used to be.
And I just think if I had my memory from back then I could actually do this job
well.
Um,
but
this,
take some of this that ever give me any of those Alpha brain.
I kept a,
uh,
send you a bunch of it.
I'll have a bunch sent to you.
I had this game,
my,
my friends were a over one night and we were having a conversation and they just
kept doing that where they couldn't think of stuff.
And I thought of an idea for a game show that I pitched,
sold it didn't get picked up.
And then I pitched and sold to another network and we,
and it didn't get picked up and it was basically,
it was,
uh,
an old lady is called ass granny.
And it was,
uh,
me living with my mother and I have kids and she keeps trying to tell them these
great stories from her life.
Like about when she ran with the bowls with Picasso or she was on the freedom
marches down south and there are these stories from her rich life,
but she keeps forgetting shit.
So she goes,
so I was out in,
you know,
I was in the capital of Washington state.
Um,
what's it called?
Uh,
And then you,
you clap in and you give her the answer.
But she tells these funny stories about her wildlife and,
and I,
and that was like the perfect fucking game show to me.
Um,
but that's how people really talk.
You catch him sometimes and it's like,
so what I do now is if somebody gets stuck,
I will give the most ridiculous answer possible and I'll keep doing it as
they're trying to think and it fucks them up.
That's not nice.
They'll be like,
what's that one?
You know,
the ones on the first year?
Yes,
because I am insecure with myself.
Greg,
a middle school was the name of this band and then it changed.
They changed it to metal shop and then they changed it to steel panther.
Okay,
got it.
Then that's the band and the guy looks in the mirror at himself when he's
playing bass.
Yeah.
Boy,
they could have saved a lot of time.
I should have kept up with the band.
Why do they keep changing their fucking names?
Why don't you like stay on their Twitter,
follow the Twitter feed?
Well,
it's one of those bands where if you go to Vegas,
which you know,
my,
my interest in Vega says as crawled,
who is zero at this point?
I used to really like it,
but it was great if you could go and you'd know,
all right,
I want to see cookie jar.
You know that that performer cookie jar?
No.
What is cookie jar?
He's like this guy who plays,
uh,
how could you possibly see that?
You know,
you know,
cookie jar,
you know.
Well,
he's a big,
he's a big name in,
in Vegas.
He's like,
yeah,
he's,
he's a guy who does,
he's got an amazing voice.
And a toupee and he sings everything from like youtube going back to Elvis and
he plays a synthesizer and gets it going in a loop and then he starts another
instrument.
He's,
he's really,
really great lounge act and so,
but if you go to Vegas,
it's important that you have like a,
what do they call steel panther.
Yeah.
You have a steel panther and a cookie jar and,
and maybe you know a comedian that's in town and then it,
then it's worth actually be in there for a couple of days there.
Yeah,
there's still some great shows.
That's cookie jar.
Whoa.
Jesus Christ.
You don't,
you don't know if he's a parody or not.
He is,
but he's not because he's so fucking good that you find yourself just,
you're not laughing at them at all.
You're,
you're there on it where there's like,
show me
and in Vegas there's one thing that appeals to me,
the idea of doing a show at the same place all the time.
I really do enjoy traveling and doing standup,
but I also liked the fact of being a desk.
I like the idea of being a destination,
like if you're going to go to see Siegfried and Roy used to be God blessed them
restless faster or whatever.
He's still alive.
He used to be a lot of people.
It is Penn and teller.
This,
there's certain people that go to Vegas and they'll still like wrap their trip
around going to see Penn and teller.
They're like,
we got tickets to see Penn and teller.
This is what we're going to do.
We're going to catch Cirque de Solei.
We're going to do like that's a destination.
Like those Cirque du Soleil shows.
They do like Zumanity or whatever.
Oh,
those.
Those are destinations.
Well,
somebody who I know,
a younger girl I worked with on a show and she's like,
yeah,
my family's in town.
We're going to go out to Vegas.
I go to you and do this.
She's like,
we got tickets to see Vinny favor.
Read out.
That's a destination in Vegas now.
Good for him.
That's what you want to be.
Joe,
do you want to be fitting fear free and say that?
I said good for him.
I'm trying to be positive.
You fuck is the worst comedian ever.
Oh No,
you didn't.
I'll piss on your little picnic.
I'll piss on your little big mag.
Well,
carrot top has got a great fucking Gig.
I mean,
I think that guy makes some insane eight or $9 million a year,
does a genre of comedy that is,
he's the best at,
you know,
well,
he's not just the best.
He's annihilated the genre.
Right.
There's no more prop comic.
Right,
right.
I remember who pointed it out.
I forgot who.
I think it was Todd glass.
It was pointing it out.
He's like,
there's no one else.
Like,
they used to be a genre.
They used to be guys who are ventriloquist fucking amazing.
When Jeff,
uh,
Jeff Dunham and peanut,
he fucked that.
There's no one left.
It was like this,
of course,
auto and George still in New York and there's a couple of guys like Willie Tyler
and Lester and those guys are still working.
But as far as like new guys that are ventriloquist,
it's so rare to go to a comedy club and see a puppet.
It used to be one out of 20
Oh and you and I would fucking,
I remember once we did a gig out in western mass and the headliner was a puppet
guy and you and I went on ahead of him and just did nothing but puppet jokes
time and then we left before he went on.
I remember that we were so cruel back then.
We had such was such a fucking standards that we're not to be broken.
No such ideas about what's common and what's not comedy.
I know now I would kill to see a good profit.
I love that shit.
Get High and go watch a fucking proper great carrot.
Top is a good,
proper lot of people give that guy.
She also writes new material all the time.
Like he did the roast and he had a bunch of funny shit from there for the roast.
Yeah,
it's a good act.
You know what I haven't seen blown out as a genre is the guitar act.
There's guys that are big,
you know?
I think Stephen Lynch,
isn't he a big guitar?
Yes.
Just guys that are big,
but that haven't really cracked to the point that carrot top has or Jeff Dunham
has.
Well,
how about a guy like Michael Winslow?
Who a sound effects guy?
Like how many sound effects guys are there?
Have you ever heard that guy?
Do whole lot of love.
Yeah.
Pull that up.
Yeah,
we'll up.
Michael Winslow.
All in is Babylon.
It's fucking incredible.
Do you remember the line?
So incredible.
You won't believe it's actually just coming out of his mouth.
And who was the comic who had that joke?
Uh,
in Boston?
Alara Pucci and it was a is this is an auto mechanic singing led Zeppelin.
You need coolant here.
It,
so he's on a show doing this led Zeppelin and went,
when did the original artists,
this is Michael Winslow from police academy.
All right.
It's insanely talented voice artist.
Listen to this.
So it was one guy with a
tar and here comes Winslow.
That's his mouth.
That's him singing.
The host has this look on his face.
Like what the fuck?
Okay.
The drums is all
mountains.
Come on man.
That's his mouth.
Amazing.
Okay.
It's incredible.
That's incredible.
That's great.
Yeah.
I remember seeing them do purple haze one time and he was like,
excuse me while I kiss a flight.
And it was like a,
yeah,
I mean that was a very Hendrickson version of Zeplin.
Yeah.
It was more of a,
yeah.
More blues or torsion and,
yeah,
yeah.
Well I think he's a bit of Hendrix Fan.
How could you not be,
you know,
there's a thing that,
uh,
I was watching this Anthony Bordain episode the other night and it was,
he was talking about going to Japan for the first time and then encountering
Japanese culture and Japanese cuisine and seeing like how insane their society
is and how different it is and how he acquainted it.
He,
he,
uh,
said it was like,
it was like taking acid for the first time,
but it was also like the feeling that it left him.
It was like the feeling that Eric Clapton and Jimmy page must have had when
Jimmy Hendrix came to town.
Right.
I go,
fuck,
now what?
That's what everybody,
the hat,
right.
Anybody that talks about like,
like I've heard people say that like Jimi Hendrix is overrated.
I've,
I've had arguments with people but like this podcast called the Joe Rogan
experience,
cause I'm a Jimi Hendrix Fan.
I mean there's,
I stole it straight from Jimi Hendrix when I,
when,
when I'm listening to like Jimi Hendrix,
even today I think I find it insanely and town,
insanely talented,
insanely amazing.
But when you take it about like this guy coming out in the 1960s with this,
like this was so alien and revolutionary and so different from anything that had
come before.
Hmm.
Well you listen to like a [inaudible] child,
like Voodoo child,
slight return,
the slower version of it.
Like all of it did the,
the sounds that guy was in the way he was putting it together and he was,
and it was about war.
I mean,
ultimately he's doing fucking,
you know,
he did that and machine gun at the,
um,
uh,
what was the New Year's eve?
Tell me did it the M in San Francisco,
I have to fill it was live at the Fillmore and like the whole thing was about
Vietnam.
It's like that was the undertones of it.
He's constantly weaving machine gun fire and they and rockets coming down and it
was like his,
his ability,
like I heard the story about at um,
uh,
Monterey Festival in 1967 which launched not only Hendricks but a Otis Redding
and um,
who is the other,
there was somebody else huge that got launched.
Was it the,
who might've been the WHO's first major performance in North America also,
but when he came on they say that backstage.
Everybody always wonders.
Like,
what was it like,
like what was going on backstage?
It must've been,
were they all like refund together with ever?
Apparently Hendrix had a,
um,
sergeant pepper's had just come out and Hendricks had learned the entire album
and was playing the guitar and the lead on the entire album while everybody,
like I,
I forget who else was there,
like sat around.
Just mesmerized.
Wow.
Yeah,
Dude.
Pull up.
Hendricks plays Monterey pop 1967 finale.
Wild thing.
He plays it.
Uh,
this was 1967 the world's introduction to this guy,
he was only around for a short amount of time.
That's what's such a mind fuck.
And he was so young.
He was 27 when he was dead.
Yeah,
27,
him and Morrison and Janis Joplin,
three of arguably the greatest of all
was not a drug addict.
He,
you know,
he happened to die while he was fucked up.
I think it was alcohol or whatever.
And it was famous stories about him using acid,
but he really used acid as a way to expand his mind.
He was not an addict in any way.
The way,
when you think of somebody like Jim Morrison,
well I don't,
you know,
there's,
I don't know what happened to Hendricks.
Obviously he died like when I was a baby,
choked on his own vomit.
But you know,
there's a huge book out by,
um,
one guy,
he was a foreign body guard or something like that.
The claims that his manager had Hendricks killed because a Hendrix was leaving
him.
He did.
His first manager was a gangster.
And not only was Hendrix killed,
but his girlfriend was thrown off the roof of a building the same night.
No,
like really close to that.
Like after the murder,
his girlfriend was thrown off the roof of the building.
Oh yeah.
And uh,
you know,
I don't know if this guy is right or wrong,
but the guy was a,
um,
the guy was in a band too.
I think he was in,
um,
fuck he was in one of those,
uh,
early,
early sixties.
Rock and roll bands.
The Guy,
the guy who was the manager?
Yes.
Hey.
Yeah,
no,
not the guy.
Who's the manager?
The guy who wrote the book.
Oh
yeah.
Um,
it's also a story about how like it was either going to be the who are Hendricks
closing out Monterey and there was like a little bit of a drama about it and I
think that's why he lit his fire,
his guitar and fire at the end of his set.
Listen to how good this is,
man.
I look how little he uses his left hand to Strunk.
He's doing a lot of the notes,
just banging his right fingers down on the fret
board.
Wow.
The animals.
That's who the guy was from.
Eric Burdon in the animals.
The guy who worked for the band I think could run of the most underrated rock
bands in history.
The animals.
I'm pretty sure that's who it was.
Wow.
Man.
All this playing lead,
playing rhythm,
guitar,
singing and chewing gum at the same time.
Chewing gum
and not looking ever eyes closed.
Ooh.
And doing Michael Winslow noises with his mouth
flap.
Yeah.
This is,
people kind of have to understand how new this was
and hasn't been done since.
You know,
prince is the closest that's come to this.
Well,
there's been some interesting guys since that,
you know,
there's some guys that don't get any credit like you know who uh,
Gary Clark is now.
Garrett Clark is a,
this guy out of Texas.
I think that's his name.
Shit.
How much did Lenny Kravitz want to be this
Gary Clark Jr Carter?
Is that it?
Gary Clark Jr or you just,
you get that left hand in the air is all being played.
That's on the front
ports.
Yeah.
This is it.
It's Gary Clark Jr.
That's his name.
Yeah.
Pull up this song.
Bright Lights.
This is a,
I mean,
I don't want to compare this dude to Hendrix and give him a lot of grief,
but this,
this guy is a bad motherfucker that doesn't get as do
and I don't understand why pull up bright lights.
This is,
I mean Guessi does,
I'm looking at one of his songs.
It has 470,000 hits,
so I guess he does get his due,
but um,
he's still around.
I may do is playing.
Oh yeah.
Two drummers.
Oh,
this is him playing some pop festival or something.
What does it say?
Crossroads.
Crossroads Guitar Festival.
2010 crossroads Guitar Festival on Warner Brothers records.
It was pretty big.
Much more vocal oriented.
The fucker did
losses.
See,
here's the song that I've never heard on the radio.
I've never heard this guy on the radio head.
Yeah.
I mean I don't,
maybe he's being played on the radio and I'm not aware,
but this is one of the things I fucking love about the Internet.
Is it a dude like that with some 1970s cop glasses and the crazy beard?
You're going to know my name by the end of
this impurity to this music,
you know?
Yeah.
Well it's,
yeah,
it's basic fucking Delta Blues.
Yeah.
And it's that he's doing it the right way.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
fuck that shit.
There's nothing that stands out.
You know,
there's one
thing that used to drive me fucking crazy when I was a kid and I would listen
to,
I know Whitney Houston has a beautiful voice and I know Mariah Carey could sing
her ass off,
but it was that thing that they used to do the,
Ooh,
all that extra shit you're throwing in there that like if you listen to like,
there's certain artists that don't,
they have a beautiful voice but never do that.
You're not showing off.
Yeah.
You go back Fiona Apple,
right.
Authentic,
Pure,
authentic fucking be or Sinead O'Connor.
Perfect.
Perfect example.
Or Natalie manes,
another great example,
but doesn't have to.
Then you go back to like Sarah Vaughan where she was showing off but not,
not in a fucking,
he was in a playful way that was very much part of jazz and blues back then.
Ella Fitzgerald,
they were those that was flourished.
That wasn't the bait.
The base of the song wasn't twisting a fucking note to death.
It was just little like they would do scat singing a little bit in the middle.
But Sarah Vaughan's voice to me is still the greatest female vocals of all time.
Yeah,
there's been a lot of great fucking female vocalists,
man.
And I,
there's a thing about hearing a great female voice that's very different than
hearing a great man voice,
like great female voices.
Like people give Cheryl crow a hard time because she does a lot of poppy
bullshit.
But that bitch can sing her ass off.
She's got some songs.
She has this one song that she did with kid rock.
Um,
I forget what the name of it is.
A valid one.
The ballad one weather.
Yeah.
I saw you last night.
Her voice is just so beautiful.
It does something to your body,
like it just calms you down or something that puts you in a different place.
You hear it,
you go,
God damn,
that bitch just nailed it.
She nailed it.
If you're ever down,
you know,
sometimes you get,
you get,
there's always that you've got to call an audible on your depression.
Like sometimes you start to feel it and you go,
all right,
I got to snap the fuck out.
Let me get some coffee and work out.
And there's other times where it's,
it's got to,
the fingers are deep in and you've gotta go,
I gotta go down with this one.
Oh No,
I gotta roll.
I've got to go underwater water and roll a few with this bitch and then I'll get
a role with the depression radiator,
all the depression.
So when you hit that,
you grab a grab a blue
by.
Um,
uh,
oh.
What the fuck is her name?
Um,
Sarah on?
No,
no,
no.
Late sixties,
early seventies.
Oh,
come on Greg.
You're playing that fucking game again.
Oh No,
Greg,
you're in the hole right now.
Fuck.
Oh Lou,
look up blue.
Not Janice.
Oh,
I leann rimes
Leann rimes.
Leann rimes has a beautiful voice.
Eiffel 65.
Joni Mitchell,
Joni Miss Joni Mitchell blue might be the greatest,
uh,
I it top 10 albums of all time.
I put,
I put that album in there,
but you gotta be sad for it.
You know the singer tits off that people don't realize it's gonna sound
ridiculous.
Miley Cyrus,
she's got a fucking cover.
Fuck you Brian.
She's got a cover of a Dolly Parton's Jolene that I just put up on Twitter.
It's fucking fantastic.
He had no problem with her.
But why did she make such shit like that thing that she did at the video music
awards,
like who was managing her?
They didn't know.
Come to her and go,
listen,
this other song is fucking good.
Like if you could do shit like this,
like God damn bitch,
like this is really,
really,
really good
to get radio play.
It's so specific what you need to do and she's addicted to the corporate cock
now she's,
she came up a child star and she can't accept not being number one.
So they get led around by their nose is do this,
do this.
Maybe she's just a kid and doesn't know what the fuck she's doing.
I think that she's a little more mature than that because she gave some advice
to,
um,
to a Justin Bieber when he stopped,
you know,
he started,
he's acting out a little bit and apparently she reached out to him and said,
look man,
take a breather.
Go ahead.
Go on the sidelines for a while.
I get your shit together because it's a long road.
Then she really,
yeah.
So I kind of respected that.
The,
well,
maybe she's just,
you know,
it needs to mind her own business
matches
fucking walking around with a giant foam number one finger rubbing her ass
against some guy's cock on TV.
We'll play this Joe lead please Jolie video.
Pull that,
pull that video up.
Miley Cyrus.
Joey's.
I'm like my,
this,
it's on my Twitter feed.
My first podcast of every year.
I make predictions for the following year 10.
Yeah.
I say whether the Dow will be up or down shit.
Like,
oh,
all day.
You'd be the predictor in Karnak.
No,
I'm not good at it.
And for three years straight I've predicted Miley Cyrus having some kind of a
drug blowout thing and the media and it hasn't quite happened yet,
but it's getting there.
She smoked weed on some a watch,
right?
I'm talking about like some Brittany Spears Shit.
I keep predicting.
I don't
think she's listened to this man.
Put it in the beginning.
This is fucking good man.
I like that video.
It's a nice,
that's a nice shot.
No,
let me tell you something.
If you can separate her from all the controversy and just listen to this.
He didn't know anything about her Childhood Star Dad,
Billy Ray Cyrus.
You'd be like,
that's a bad ass bitch.
Watch her.
Well cause she's got a husky strong voice.
She's a bad ass bitch dude.
She can do this.
I mean she does that Shit but she can do this.
This smell is like more the spring
be with you Jolie.
Come on son.
That's undeniable.
That's,
that's raw talent.
Yeah,
no problem.
I got no problem with his swinging around on a fucking ball half naked.
She looks great.
How many years I spent sitting on the couch next to my kids watching Hannah
Montana.
I want to kill myself.
This is redemption.
Why did you watch it?
Cause like you know,
even you could leave the room.
They're watching.
Do you have to be there?
I thought she was hot.
She was so young.
I haven't these legal to say that.
No.
Did you hear this fucking thing you're going to do in the UK where they're going
to actually like you're going to have to,
this is a proposal.
You're going to have to request whether or not you get access to porn,
get to opt in.
What the fuck?
Really,
really there.
How depressing is that?
It's the present.
Because you know we're headed towards is that uh,
I forget what that act is,
where the government is going to be able to decide who gets a who is basically
some companies are going to get faster,
high speed Internet access than others.
That's what keeps coming up in Congress is the ability to control proceed and
control,
uh,
internet speed.
And so,
you know,
the Internet right now is free loose and you know,
democratic,
but over the next five,
10 years it's going to get,
it's going to get bottleneck that you know,
the little sites that you want to get out.
Democracy now,
Shit like that.
Good luck to me.
You have a fucking dial up service.
Meanwhile Disney is going to be flowing through and high def.
I'm not sure I agree with that.
I don't think that's,
no,
it's a real bill.
Yeah.
But I don't think it's going to get through.
I mean even if it does get through,
I don't think it's going to stop a potential second internet or a third
interview.
I already have internet.
Right.
There's already a second one that I think they used for,
I think at universities and the military are,
so I'm using it right now.
Um,
I don't know that.
Okay.
No.
When other countries are creating their own,
they're calling an intranet like a down,
is it?
Brazil and France are talking about how they can have a national internet.
Yeah,
we'll Brazil's reeling from the finding out.
The NSA has been spying on them for all these years as is Germany as is a lot of
other cramps and France.
You know there's a recent article that I was reading about Microsoft coding
windows and coating their encryption to battle the NSA and I was like,
this is,
this is incredible.
Our own country,
I can't believe I'm reading this,
like why is Microsoft working for the terrorists or or the terrorist,
the fucking government because something's wrong here.
When you got a company that's openly talking about working on their encryption
to keep the national security agency from peering into people's computers,
like what are we saying here?
What the fuck?
It's not only that,
but it's not like Microsoft isn't already lobbying congress.
It's not like they've got as much juice as any company in America and they still
have to build firewalls against the government.
I had a conversation this past week with a guy that I deeply respect.
It was telling me that he thinks Edward Snowden's a trader and should be in jail
and he doesn't give a fuck if they're going to look into his emails because as
long as it prevents terrorism,
and I was,
I was like,
Oh wow,
look what's going on here.
I've been like,
can I come in your house and just fucking look around?
Well,
what kind of a,
I didn't understand the law,
the logic behind it.
Like who do you think these people are they daddy?
Are they these perfect egalitarian world leaders who are only,
they only think in,
in the most beautiful way possible.
They're there without ego or fear,
insecurity.
They make the right decisions every time.
Are they that or are they just people with jobs that are able to peer in new
email because it appears that it's that,
well,
go back to Watergate.
I mean,
just the,
the little amount that they,
you take a w this government now may not be threatening to you and the state of
the government may not be threatening.
The status quo is pretty safe right now.
We're ready.
Stocks are going up.
And,
uh,
there's no political prisoners,
but that should change as fast as the tea party gets into office.
And the Christian right is indulged and they suddenly start saying,
we want to go back and see who signed a petition for abortion rights.
Cause all sudden abortions are illegal.
And they want to know who's going to be fighting against them and they're gonna
start accessing shit that it may not be now,
but in 10 years you're not going to want a digital history that's available to
anybody in the government that that's in power.
Well that's also one of the things that the NSA has been looking into.
They've been looking into finding out people's porn history so that they could
use them to discredit opponents.
Of course,
because you know,
it was a lot of people out there that didn't a freaky shit.
Right.
And by the way,
if you look at porn these days,
you look at like go to one of those porn sites,
let's free porn sites and you enter that,
you click categories and you know,
like Jesus little wheezes.
It gets very specific.
Yes it does.
And Weird Shit.
Like,
what have you found out that your congressman was only in the anal cream pies?
I,
how would you deal with that?
Like,
Hey,
that's on him.
That's all.
But then you found out the other guy,
he just likes watching straight couples porn.
Hey,
Bob is one of us.
He's a regular guy.
He wants to represent Minnesota and our quality healthy way.
Sure he watches a little porn,
but who doesn't?
But here's the kind of porn.
He was
watches guys and in fact,
white guys and white girls missionary position,
look,
their hands are interlocked.
Meanwhile,
his opponent,
Steve,
mostly tranny porn,
mostly anal cream pies in tranny porn.
He likes to see
the dripping juices of a man leaking out of it.
The booty of a man.
It's really,
um,
it's anybody's game and the future because we're leaving a fucking big footprint
and I don't know,
maybe we're being naive and living that way in the first place.
Well,
I think we should crack down on anyone who tries to control anything instantly.
I think we should boycott them.
I think we should rise up.
I think anytime you see anything where they're trying to control people and it's
not justified attack on the Internet,
it's,
yeah,
it's the only way it's gonna work out.
Like they have to realize that there's real repercussions for trying to control
people in that.
And you know,
and then there's,
there's also,
there's things that I think that people do online because of anonymity and
because of the fact that this is a new thing to be able to interact with people
without any social repercussions,
without seeing their face when you insult them.
Because of that,
there's a lot of mean evil shit that goes down on the Internet.
And I agree that there's something gross about that.
And maybe there's some sort of a compromise in that regard where identities can
be exposed if someone turns out to be a real piece of shit online.
But
I think they're doing youtube now.
I think you have to start your Facebook,
eh,
one of them.
You have to actually,
if you make comments,
your identity has to be searchable.
Yeah.
Well Google is also being owned.
Our owns youtube now,
you know,
so that's prowl owns youtube.
Yeah.
Shit.
So that's probably where that's coming from.
Wow.
Well what do you think about the group anonymous?
I think there's a real need for something,
whether it's an anonymous,
call it whatever you want to call it.
I like,
I like the name of anonymous cause I like the principle behind it,
but I think they do a lot of good shit when things go bad.
They did big chased after this girl,
they found this,
there was a video of this woman who was throwing puppies into the,
into the water.
She was throwing them into a river and people were horrified.
They went after that pitch.
Right.
And I think they should,
that's a sociopath is a person who's tossing puppies into a river.
Like that's fucked.
That's fucked to watch.
Yeah.
I think in situations like that,
I think it's good to have a United front to have a bunch of people who recognize
a,
a moral issue,
like something that's morally wrong and realize they can do something about it
and they could bring in the law.
They could actually find someone and inform the on them,
you know?
Yeah.
They're the renegade that,
you know,
like the cop who can't get the criminal because of the rules and they can go
around it.
And then the obvious danger is,
well,
first of all,
anonymous is a loose network of people because by their very nature,
they don't know each other.
They just have certain ones they don't meet,
they don't,
there's no website for them.
It's just people that have the capacity to get online and hack seem to have a
sensibility who called themselves anonymous of going after big business when
they're divulging your information.
Um,
sometimes even just showing the government where there's open,
yeah.
What'd you call him?
Portals into their systems.
But the obvious danger is what if they just,
I don't like guys to,
uh,
you know,
talk about,
um,
equal rights.
They don't like,
you know,
it's because they have no,
uh,
no.
Um,
accountability.
Who knows what their,
what their moral code is.
Yeah.
Well there's,
there's also the fact that you can't have a group of people.
You can't,
you can't have a giant group of people because they act as a group done.
And people love groups.
They love being a part of groups.
They love acting as a group.
It's almost like it has to be,
it has to be a non group.
Right.
You know,
the moral outrage of people and like having things like,
it's almost like there should be a list of what companies should be avoided if
you,
uh,
don't want to support unethical practices.
Yeah.
And by unethical,
what it should almost be more specific.
Like if you go to,
uh,
there's certain website you can log in,
what are the issues that if 50 questions and it asks you certain issues,
where do you stand one to five strongly support this,
you know,
environmental or,
small government,
whatever your thing is.
And then by the end of it,
they can then send you to a group that most represents your collective morality.
And then they will tell you what to boycott,
what not to boycott as opposed to being told by a certain news station,
uh,
you know,
think this way by this way,
because they're assuming that you all have the same set of beliefs that should
be more honed.
Yeah,
that's a,
I think there's some value in doing something like that and trying to figure out
what people like and try to categorize people in certain ways.
But I think there's always the,
the,
the real issue with not being able to totally locked down a person's personality
just from a bunch of questions and it's so flat and one dimensional.
Right.
You know,
a person might fill out all the forms and pick out all the things that you agree
with,
then you meet them and their personality sucks.
Right,
right.
And you're like,
you're fucking annoying.
I'm not in a group of this asshole.
Hey.
Yeah.
And it's like you said,
a gone back when you were talking about people that will take a survey about
whether or not they think dinosaurs and people lived together like stupid people
take the survey.
Exactly.
And I mean,
you think of the fact that like Mitt Romney was neck and neck with Obama then
lost by 20%.
How the fuck did that happen?
Yeah,
it was negative.
Well,
who knows what's real.
Yeah.
That's the other problem when it comes to votes.
Who knows what the fuck is going on when you're actually voting,
when you watch that HBO Hacking Democracy.
Oh yes.
A documentary now.
Oh my goodness.
It's all about the,
the,
the voting issue and the,
um,
the Bush election with Gore and uh,
how it's been proven that you can,
not only can you manipulate the votes with those Diebold machines,
they since changed name Diebold because
of this documentary.
They changed their corporation named,
they became something else.
Like,
let me,
well,
the guy who was like one of the main sponsors from Florida,
the Bush campaign,
and he made fucking machines that you could alter with a third party,
like a third party,
not the person counting the vote,
not the person voting,
but a third party can inject information and change the actual results of the
vote.
Right.
And no one did anything.
No one went to jail,
no one,
nothing happened.
This HBO thing came out and that that was the fucking end of it
and they lost all the paperwork.
That company after the election,
it was all carted off somehow in a rush and then went missing.
And the Al Franken wrote a whole book about it.
Yeah.
Diebold is changing its name.
That's what they,
they changed it to what they call it now.
Hmm.
I have to go take a piss.
Can I go for a minute?
Yeah.
Okay.
Votings just like total bullshit Gregg.
Yup.
Go ahead and pee.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I wished that I could believe 100% that your vote counted,
but I hate the whole system when it comes to like electorial college and I hate
the whole idea of a representative and state representatives and that your,
your vote only really doesn't go towards like one person.
It doesn't really count towards who gets elected.
It counts towards who gets elected as a representative and then how many
electoral votes your state carries and how much weight your state carries in the
national election.
You see it all and it's like impossibly complicated.
And if you were a cynic,
which I guess I am in a lot of ways,
he would look at it and go,
this is designed for fuckery.
This is designed to make it so that they can manipulate it.
It's ultimately no one,
no one is really,
you don't really get one vote.
No one gets a vote on everything.
Everything's like that.
I look at taxes,
look how crazy confusing taxes already it didn't have normal person.
You get all these forms and all this like literature.
That makes no sense.
Let's not even half of it.
It's not even English,
it's like old English or something like counting English.
But it's like,
it's like,
it seems like there's a lot of things in the government that just need to be
rehauled you know,
updated like,
you know,
voting should be online,
like just like you say online,
uh,
using really high security,
which probably is possible.
You could probably do that.
You could definitely do that.
People that are cynics,
listen,
they bank billions and billions of dollars every day gets transferred online.
Banking online is a fact and yeah,
it gets manipulated.
Occasionally people,
People's credit cards get hacked,
but it's pretty God damn good banking online works.
You could vote online easily.
They don't want you to vote online because if you can vote online,
you will lose all the power.
If you actually,
if there's independent servers that get to dictate who gets elected for things,
Holy Shit.
Do you lose power?
And if it's not independent service,
why isn't it?
Why?
Why would you,
why would it be the government servers?
Well,
let's,
let's have,
let's have people chip in and know.
We'll create some sort of a coalition for fair voting and then we all vote
online.
So you'll have your regular election mean.
Let's just try it as a goof,
a Lark,
as you will for the first couple of years.
Let's not have our votes actually count,
but let's see what the people's vote actually is.
A test.
Yes.
And let's add that.
Let's make it real simple.
Put it on your Facebook when you log in.
Would you do us a favor here and just vote who you want for president?
And if you want,
if you have time,
vote for some other shit too.
And let's just find out what the fuck do we go through this sealed [inaudible]
and if we fail,
and by the way,
then we could also have an independent analysis of the actual numbers,
the numbers of people voting 18 to 34 the numbers of people voting,
you know,
such and such and what incomes and what have you.
And it would be a hundred percent accurate and reliable because it would be
based on your Facebook or whatever,
you know,
I don't want to give Facebook a plug,
whatever,
whatever the fuck it is.
Google plus Twitter.
Yeah.
Twitter,
whatever it's based on,
uh,
as far as like your login,
you know how you do that?
Like you can log into websites through your Twitter and then you can actually
tweet like articles from that website.
That's how it should be.
And if they can verify,
verify who you are,
verify your information like they can with Facebook and then your hour with
Twitter and then you're done.
Right.
No,
I'm,
I'm with you 1000% on that.
And,
um,
you know,
uh,
I've so God crushing that the Obamacare website was so bad because that,
that alone will stop that from happening for at least another five,
10.
I think it's silly to think it wouldn't be bad if it's made by the government
and it's the first time website.
It's silly to think that that was good.
I mean,
I think that people's expectations with this being able to stand up to the
amount of traffic it was going to get ridiculous and it got more traffic than
they thought,
which is part of the problem.
Of course.
How would you know?
You can't know until you do it in like every website,
there's got to be a Beta period.
Most like big websites when they launched,
they launched in Beta first.
They check,
they check.
But when you're the government,
they assume that you know what the fuck you're doing.
What's more evidence that they don't,
they probably want it to get it out before the Supreme Court overturned it
again,
somehow.
I don't understand all this man.
I don't understand how something could be a law and you know all these people
were fighting against that law.
I don't send the,
I don't understand the arguments for it and I don't understand the arguments
against it.
I don't understand any arguments against giving people health care.
I think the ultimate goal for sure,
she'd be making sure that everyone is covered if they get injured or sick cause
we all know that that is what sets poor people completely into a whole.
If you get injured at work,
if you get sick at work and you rely check to check and then all of a sudden
you're fucked and you're out of the hospital bills,
which can be astronomical.
The number one cause of bank or SMI and the country as medical bills.
I think anybody who doesn't think that people deserve healthcare,
I think they're crazy.
I think we should have a national healthcare and I think it should be free.
I don't think it should be,
the government has to force people to buy health care.
I don't think it should be that corporations are forced to pay for their
employees healthy.
I don't necessarily think it should be any of those things.
I think it should be a part of what our taxes go to.
I think it's better fucking street.
Yeah,
cleaning and health coverage.
Yeah.
Well you should be able to decide.
I mean,
look,
if 48% if you make more than $250,000 a year,
you're in some 48% tax bracket or whatever the number is that has a lot of
goddamn money.
And the idea that that doesn't come with a dental care program is fucking
ridiculous.
You know,
if you make quarter million dollars and you give $125,000 a year to the
government,
that's kind of crazy.
It's kind of crazy that you don't get health care.
Like what are you doing with all that money?
Like where's that going?
Yeah,
it's going to war.
You're right,
it is going to war.
And that's ridiculous.
And when you seen in in perspective like that,
I think that's one of the things that we're getting now that we never got
before.
The actual numbers,
they always like $3 trillion deficit.
It always seemed insurmountable and crazy and weird.
But now because we're being hammered every day with information because of
independent news sites,
independent websites,
independent,
like the young Turks and all these different independent news sources where
they'll show you with no bias with no they don't.
They don't have anybody that's telling them what to say.
This is just what their take on something is look at the numbers and they can go
on and rant about it as long as they want.
And when that something like that happens,
those ideas spread out and they start launching and then people start tweeting
these ideas back and forth to each other.
So we start,
we're starting to scrutinize things like the budget and how much money goes to
things.
And this Obamacare thing is also forcing that argument in a lot of away.
Yeah.
There's a lot of statistics like you know,
first of all you have to attack the spin and if the right is trying to tell you
that small businesses are going to be crippled because of Obamacare or put out
of business,
well that's just not what the numbers say.
The numbers say that the percentage of businesses that fall underneath the
Obamacare,
uh,
um,
like there's a certain amount that it's just covered by medicare that's not
Obamacare.
So that if you disqualify that and the amount of people that the companies that
are big enough that are required are ready to provide,
uh,
um,
medical coverage for their employees.
It's like half of 1% that would be affected businesses that have to take it on
that don't already take it on.
Really.
It's all big business.
Everything's big business.
And you know,
same thing with farms.
The whole thing about like these farm bills that go through,
it's all aggro.
It's not a already called big agro.
It's not like nobody's lewd know families are losing their farms.
It's,
are you sure about this because I mean I've read a lot of things about families
losing their farms
now.
It's all hype.
What?
I don't know about that.
Are you really sure about that?
If you look at the numbers,
the amount of farms that are actually lost,
there's breaks.
They,
there's so there's so much fucking money given out to farm sustainable business
as so many tax
break,
large farms.
You're talking about corn farm subsidies.
Well,
they're all getting it.
And the truth is a lot of them are making crops that we don't need.
We don't need as much soy and corn is,
we're making it depletes the soil.
There's no rotation and what we need,
we need farms because they actually have some semblance of rotating crops and,
um,
you know,
using the,
the cattle,
using the manure from the cat,
everything feeds each other as opposed to these big farms.
It's just like we can't sustain the,
the world on,
uh,
you know,
on beef.
Yeah.
Well,
there's also the issue with feeding cows beef,
which is not a natural part of their dying.
Have you ever seen king corn the dark now?
Kevin Smith was on the podcast many years ago and um,
turned me onto it.
And it's a,
just all dictating how strong the corn industry is and how much money is
involved in making corn.
I mean,
it's,
it's crazy and it's a useless vegetable.
There's almost no nutrients in corn.
Yeah.
It's not natural like for you to process it.
It doesn't,
your body doesn't like it.
It's why shit.
And corn is like always synonymous.
You know,
I'd eat the shit out of her corn.
Why are you seeing shit in our corner?
Right.
And not seeing Broccoli in there
cause it has a very thick cell wall that doesn't break down.
And so what they did,
they made some kind of deal where they're making it into ethanol.
They put all this fucking corn into ethanol.
We don't need corn to put into gas.
That was like a thing in one year.
They said,
well,
we can always just fucking burn it up and put it into guests.
We don't,
we shouldn't be growing corn to do that.
So I mean,
I don't know a lot about it,
but I do know that I've read articles about,
um,
small farms being run out of business and they were all,
they've already been bought up by the big companies.
The ones that are left from my understanding,
are not going to be,
uh,
destroyed by
the government.
Well I don't,
I don't know.
I don't have enough information to add to that,
but I think it is bizarre that we're like as a practice feeding animals food
that's not supposed to be eaten.
Right.
And there we have to force antibiotics and if you don't force feed them
antibiotics,
if they don't get antibiotics,
they develop all these lesions and their stomachs because their body doesn't
want to break down all this corn.
The grass eaters,
they're supposed to be grass eaters.
You ever have grass fed beef?
Do you buy grass fed beef?
No,
I buy it exclusively now.
It tastes better.
Where do you get at whole foods?
A lot of a organic grocery store.
Oh then I probably do eat sprouts.
No,
you got to ask for it.
Oh yeah.
Cause a lot of,
like even when I was at,
I was at whole foods and I was asking for it and the butcher was actually trying
to steer me towards um,
grass fed meat.
And he was like,
it's actually tastes here or try to steer me towards corn fed meat.
And he's like,
it's actually tastier is more marbling.
And I was like,
dude,
I know what I like.
I'd like to get that.
Please don't like you.
What are you saying?
Like you're telling me to eat something that's less healthy.
Like you're saying it's tastier.
I don't even agree.
I don't agree.
It's taste here.
It's a matter of choice and second of all it's been demonstrated that the shit
is not that good for you.
Like when you're eating corn fed beef,
you're eating a sick animal.
The reason why they're so fat and Marbley,
it's their fucking ready to die.
Like it's,
it's like a fucking,
it's like Rob Ford.
It's like if you ate the mayor of Toronto,
like he'd be a corn fed cow looking at me like I don't have the fuck.
Is that guy still alive?
Smoking crack and eating pussy there.
Charlie Sheen,
man,
if he came
to America he would be the King of Florida.
Fuck yeah.
If he just went to two.
If he just moved to America long enough where they trusted him and decided to
run for mayor of Florida,
he would be the king of Florida governor rather.
I think he got a reality show already and then he was such a fuck up.
They cancelled it after like one episode,
but that's the reality shell.
I want to watch.
The reality show is just the Internet.
You don't want an organize bullshit Beverly hills housewives version of that
guy.
You want him doing impromptu live press conferences where he talks about a woman
accusing him of eating her pussy and says,
I have plenty to eat at home.
So you see that?
I wonder what his wife and his wife said about that because that's almost an
insult saying that there's probably said she pretty,
she probably said a ask him again.
I think we got some leftovers here at the house.
It doesn't sound like you.
She has a huge pussy.
He said he has plenty to eat at home now that he's not eating enough of it.
You know,
I think that,
uh,
cause I'm happily married and this is Toronto.
This isn't some podunk town.
This is the biggest fucking city and right.
Biggest city in Canada by far.
Yeah.
It's an enormous city.
Massive metropolitan city because of Paul and very international and when my
favorite places to perform,
I love it.
Love to run it.
Yeah.
I love this guy to listen to this.
Listen,
this press conference,
I mean it's fucking fantastic.
He goes out there,
he's got a fucking Football Jersey on.
He's a thousand pounds overweight,
even beats Charlie sheen with overeating.
But he just talks,
they stick all the things that he's so relaxed and calm.
Comment yesterday.
Listen to all this.
Um,
what's going on?
Why is that
documents that was released.
There we go.
Done.
Unfortunately.
Um,
it's unfortunate to have to take the legal action.
I don't appreciate people call Atlanta a prostitute and never had a prostitute
here.
I'm very happily married at home.
Um,
this is very disturbing against,
um,
unfortunately I have to take legal action against sizes of grants and McGeorge
for stop lists and,
um,
mark Toohey,
I have to take legal action against the waiter that said I was doing lines.
Your market.
Don't wait.
The lies,
that is not true.
Um,
you know what?
It hurts my wife when,
uh,
they're calling a friend of mine a prosecuted Atlanta is not a prostitute.
She's a friend.
And it makes me sick how people are saying this.
So unfortunately I have no other choice.
I'm the last one to take legal action.
I can't,
I can't put up with it anymore.
So I've named the names,
um,
litigation.
We'll be starting shortly.
I've had enough.
That's why I warned you guys yesterday.
Be careful what you wrote.
Okay.
So that's all I have to save for now.
And the next thing I want to call a member Tanya at Hamilton and tell them that
we're going to have to spank the middle a tiger cats on.
The last thing was Olivia gone back.
Does it says that I wanted to eat her pussy?
They let,
he's gone nuts.
I've never said that in my life tour.
I would never do that.
I'm happy married.
I've got more than enough to eat at home.
Unscripted nails,
every word of it.
And the best part about that video is after he leaves,
one of the reporters goes,
I fucking love that guy.
Says it.
It's like finally something's happening
and he's naming names.
I mean,
the first thing you learn is politician is keep it vague,
keep it general.
This guy's going like,
and Billy the waiter down there,
he said that
I was doing lines in the fucking waiter says,
you're doing lines.
Most likely you're doing lines,
especially if there's a video of you smoking crack.
Right.
He admits to that.
Yes.
He admits to the video of him smoking crack.
He's beautiful.
He is a beautiful man.
Meanwhile,
by the way,
he does good.
These Honami has gone through the roof with him as the mayor.
She's not a bad man.
He's also a guy who came up through going to the projects,
helping out the working poor and you know,
being an inspiration.
I think he coaches a football team and the reason why he's an off his favorite
[inaudible] rating is not that fucking low considering.
And it's because the poor people remember where this guy came from and he,
they know what he's done for them.
They'll overlook who gives a shit.
Nobody really should give a shit the crack.
Yeah.
The rest of it.
Who Cares?
It's kind of funny that it's cracked too.
It's like you went for the most ghetto of ghetto drugs and he did it with a
bunch of black people and they got videos of him.
I mean,
does he not know what a fucking cell phone is when they're holding a cell phone
in front of him?
Yeah.
Look at Mike Tyson.
Shit's the best part where he said,
he w he wants to fight Mike Tyson.
He's like,
I'll kill Mike Tyson.
And he said,
Oh,
you haven't seen that?
And that's the best one.
I've seen that.
Oh my God.
I,
I've seen one where you challenged some guy too.
I'm an MMA fight.
Maybe that's it.
He challenged,
I've only watched like five seconds of it.
I was like,
this guy's crazy.
So I was like,
Jason Ellis,
he's amazing,
right?
Well,
I mean,
we had Marion Barry,
but that guy was like,
not like this.
He didn't have the dimensions
guy had.
He also does not have the ability to own it.
Marion Barry lied about it at all.
Like we,
Marion Barry was on opiod.
Uh,
and Anthony and I got to ask him some questions and uh,
I was a person.
Yes,
in person.
It's close as you are to me.
And I was like,
what about the crack thing when they caught you smoking crack?
Like I knew he only had like five minutes and I was like,
I am going to ask this like right away.
Like you can't like beat around the bush.
He's in and out.
He's doing a bunch of different reviews.
I go,
what was that about?
What was going on there?
He goes,
they,
they did not know whether or not what I had was crack.
Okay.
What they have is a video.
Me Smoking.
I go,
but what was it?
Was it crack?
Like wouldn't,
wouldn't answer.
It wouldn't say,
listen man,
I got a little crazy.
I fucked up.
I smoked a little crack.
That's what
it should never said
I did lines.
That's an outright lie.
It's an insult.
My friend is not a prostitute.
As soon as you have to see,
your friend is not a prostitute
twice man by name.
Oh cool.
Yeah,
I've got to that fucking guy.
I'm telling you.
First degree murder,
Mike Tyson,
he has this series walking around.
It was fucking scared.
I need fucking
10 minutes out.
Absolutely fuck around me.
Like my brothers are adults telling me you were liars.
These hurts or it's
his fucking daddy.
Oh my God,
he's coked up.
Oh,
how come I haven't seen this?
Everyone in the room and he keeps on saying brother like Hulk Hogan.
No fucking interference.
Brother can find wins.
I will fucking donate.
It gives up rows
15 minutes
to do it for five.
No,
no,
no.
Okay.
Now because of this video,
I'm on the side of the people trying to get him out of office.
Wow.
Because that video officially think he's out of control.
I didn't think he was out of control before.
I thought he was just being silly man.
Somebody from Toronto that I know says actually he knows that this drug dealer
that's friends with him and that's he not calling into the podcast on now.
I think they already have talked to drug dealers and I think this is like known
in Canada that like this is just ridic.
The problem is a fat guy that dom is dangerous.
Like thinking he can actually beat up Mike Tyson and then it only needs this 15
minutes and I'll have him down,
rip his eyes out like,
oh,
okay,
you're too stupid.
You're like delusional.
That's why you're so confident now.
I understand because that's the dumbest shit ever.
Veronica.
Most politicians,
the mood,
like the decisions they make in their lives,
that fucking balls that they just cheating while in office.
When you think that everything's being examined,
this camera's on the all the time and you're going to fucking cheat and you
think you're not going to get caught.
I think they've always done it.
I think guys like,
like the,
the,
the Clinton types are the JFK types that,
you know,
have this like lust for it.
I think it's always been what they got away with.
It's always been a part of it.
Someone's always swept it under the rug and so they,
they've always kept going and like they like it so much they don't want to stop.
They liked the power of it,
but no one's ever been like,
no,
that's crazy.
Yeah.
Well,
the guy down in San Diego gave us a pretty good run.
Right.
He was liberal like dozens of Leche lecturers.
Yeah.
He was a latch.
That guy was,
uh,
he's,
he's been sued by a gang of them too.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
What's so sad about him is he didn't even get any pussy.
I think he was just grabbing acids.
So amateur,
it's eighth grade.
Let's seeing that guy say that he would beat up Tyson.
He's like,
do you have any idea how fun that would fight?
That fight would be for Tyson.
Tyson would literally right now you can wake them up and tell him he has to
fight this guy.
It can be taken a nap.
And he would get in there and he'd be laughing the whole time.
Like laughing,
like,
oh,
come on big guy.
You're going to kill me.
Going to put my eyes out when you going through,
he gonna hold me down.
What's going to happen here?
You're going to rip my throat out.
Well to me from my provision,
that's a ludicrous,
but I'm willing to engage you in this contest that she,
so Juan,
if you thought Jews have the dude chasing him around party hard,
like that's a great shirt.
Where can I buy that?
Uh,
please tell me it's for sale.
It is Andrew Wk is rob Ford parties.
Andrew Wk is that,
it's the guy.
It's about saying you're a millionaire before Christmas.
I'm buying one.
I'm going to buy one right now.
Party hard with blood pouring out of his nose.
I fucking love it.
It's on Andrew's official party store.
If you want to make some money,
promote the fight Tyson versus him.
No,
he got to give him cook first and then you've got to have like 10 dudes outside
the ring at all corners with the,
the,
the fucking defibrillators.
Just ready to go.
No,
that guy is going to have a heart attack.
Like you see him pacing.
Like how does a fat guy,
that old Duke coke like that's fucking dangerous.
Cold said Dude.
How old's Rob Ford?
I think he's four.
He looks older than 54 I can remember being on being on a coke Jag and pacing
like that.
I'm saying Shit like I'm a bad mother.
Felt like I remember being in that space.
Okay,
let me stop you.
You were 19 right?
Big Fuck right,
right.
44 44 44 Jesus Christ.
It looks like shit.
Yeah,
he's deep in his 15 so what happens to rob forward over the next year?
Well,
at
different,
yeah,
most likely.
Right.
But Canada is different when it comes to their ability to get people out of
office.
You can't just pull something out of office for conduct if they don't violate
any of the state laws.
If they don't get in trouble,
steal money.
It's like a lot of things that you have to have done to get them out of office.
So right now they're just sort of taking away his power.
They're just slowly but surely making him a puppet mayor.
They were moving his power.
So that gets weird because then you're sort of like crippling your own sort of
economy and you're,
you're crippling your own government.
Like,
I don't know.
No.
The idea is that most people would quit,
but this guy's not
so I gotta quit.
He'll never quit.
He's suing them.
He's going to sue them to keep his job,
but they should show that video and then have an expert come in and you're like
a teddy atlas.
And explain what would happen if Mike Tyson and him got into an actual ring
together.
Does this make sense or would you categorize a person that's 44 years old?
It looks like there's 60 that's clearly coked out of their mind.
It looks like they ate a beach ball.
Do you,
would you categorize that as delusional to the utmost?
Bring in Dr drew.
You'd have to just bring in a few fight experts,
just bringing the Teddy Atlas and Jim Lampley and have them describe and then
have Mike Tyson and then tell him the theory,
Lee.
He said,
yeah,
have him laugh and slap it.
You know,
it was a great show that I wished was still on.
Was that a celebrity death match where you could put rob for it in the,
in the ring with Tyson and chainsaws and shit?
That was fucking great.
What happened to that show?
I think they tried to bring it back a few years ago,
but,
uh,
I was working on a show and they were doing it in the next studio,
but I obviously didn't go,
why am they had a celebrity MMA show?
Like w I would thought that someone like Fox would have tried to do that
already.
They had slept.
Remember how that celebrity boxing like scratch from saved by the bell and Todd
bridges was on it probably for that reason.
I think it did well
select.
I mean they've got that die.
If you can get celebrities to dive in,
bathing suits on TV,
mixed martial arts,
fuck diving,
you think it would be better?
I just think in terms of being exposed and embarrassed on TV diving and you
think it's embarrassing and we have to earn your bathing suit.
Oh,
you're hilarious.
More than getting the fuck.
I don't like my body though,
Dude.
I would relish the opportunity to show you my package.
Excellent.
Top where the board,
he would go over to swan dive.
Uh,
I don't think people would find that so gross.
I think fighting is be way more embarrassing guys.
Get the fuck beat out.
Yeah.
I guess the ultimate,
it's the ultimate loss of dignity for a man on TV.
Yeah.
There was,
uh,
a lot of those,
those ones where it was really sad.
What do you,
what are you putting on here?
The diving.
Typing.
Shit I'll do,
we had to wait a minute.
There's a show.
Oh,
I'm not kidding you.
It's called splash or something.
Oh,
wait,
him and that's doing it died.
Why is that chewy from the Chelsea handler show
this room making that noise?
Or was that video?
Oh God.
We had listened to him.
It was a,
yeah.
Chewy from um,
uh,
Chelsea Chelsea handler.
I forget who else.
I think it's a decent name and they dive in the water,
but he's wearing Ryan boy Tana life jacket.
It's not even showing his body.
I know.
I think it,
yeah,
that's it.
That was his thing is he wasn't going to show his body.
Other people are just wearing bathing suits.
Oh,
so some people,
hmm.
He would do it if he's wearing a leopard,
essentially.
Uh,
an outfit.
He's wearing a crazy,
oh,
it's not a,
okay,
wait a minute.
That's just his body.
That's not a life vest.
That's just his,
yeah,
like somebody not a one piece bathing suits.
Oh my God.
That's horrifying.
He cries a lot on the show.
What's,
well,
it's more than like a couple of seconds and it's a whole show.
Oh,
it's a series.
can't be,
it's a series called splash.
It's a reality show.
They get voted off standard.
Right,
right.
Every time I try to think of a joke for a reality show,
I find out that there actually was one.
I thought of this thing about what if like it was a illegal immigrants competing
for green card.
It already happened.
Oh yeah,
that's,
that's already happened.
Right?
What was that on?
Probably Fox.
No,
I forget.
I forget
in a skin tight,
wet suit.
Why?
Why shouldn't a wetsuit?
Maybe they all do.
Where
Chewy,
you guys got injured on that show.
On the typing.
So where is it and where's it?
And Greg says the host of fear factor.
That's it started
without a fucking hint of irony.
Radicular ridiculous
hunger games,
man.
Hunger Games.
Yeah,
maybe.
Right.
Well that's what everyone's always said about the fall of humanity is that if
you look at the Roman Empire,
for example,
or look back at all the various empires that have fallen before they fell,
they were filled with great access and ridiculous wealth and you know,
fat.
And although vomitorium is a misnomer,
you know what the vomitorium is,
it's actually the,
the shape of these arenas.
Like it's about how they,
the people spill out into the arena.
Oh,
there wasn't a bathroom?
No,
no,
no.
That does not what vomitorium means.
Got It.
I think people just heard that and sort of,
it might have happened.
Most likely it did that people threw up on purpose in order to keep eating.
Sure.
But it wasn't like there was the name of an arena.
They would go on,
throw up
vomitorium that's a good name.
Somebody should come up if you're putting one in Dallas and new MMA ring called
the vomitorium.
Yeah.
I think it's,
um,
it's just the way it's designed to make,
uh,
make them flow,
the audience flow.
Yeah.
You know,
like when they're being seated in shit.
Yeah.
It's a,
but it's been sort of,
uh,
over the years it's been turned into some,
you know,
it's one of those things where you're sitting around with your friends,
they used to have this thing called the vomitorium where everybody was forced to
throw up and I'm like,
Whoa,
really?
It actually is where big crowds can exit rapidly at the end of it performance.
It's like a,
an entrance like this is,
you can just be vomited out of that Obama.
Right?
Yeah.
I think that of course under,
I think that that kind of,
uh,
access,
we're definitely there were there,
you know what I mean?
Brian was just talking about how he can command his playstation four to go to
comedy central.
Like the idea that having a remote in your hand and using your thumb,
there were scientists and engineers that worked for years to come up with this.
Meanwhile,
like we're talking about trying to,
you know,
change agriculture to feed poor people in Third World nations.
That's getting,
yeah,
we gave 100,000 led.
The U s government gave 100,000 for research on that last year.
Yeah.
But I don't think that's like a fall of humanity type thing.
I think that's just a technology making lives simpler and making things more and
more accessible and more and more complex.
I think that's inevitable.
But I think when you see in things like this or when you see things like fear
factor,
we see things like where people are.
Look,
I mean there's a certain aspect of that to mixed martial arts as well.
There's a lot of people that look at mixed martial arts and they say,
even though I look at it very differently because I'm deeply involved in it,
and to me it looks like the most intense form of competition and the the
greatest challenge and a way where people find out what they're made of.
They find out what their character,
what lies inside their,
their,
their will and their courage and their physical abilities.
But some people look at it like it might as well be gladiators.
I mean,
these people are there.
They're doing that for the pleasure of the audience.
We screams and booze and turns their thumb down.
I mean,
it's these ideas that when your civilization gets to a low point is when war
becomes much more accepted.
People just randomly,
you know,
except or,
or easily accept rather that we have to kill certain amounts of people and then
easily accept that sometimes entertainment is this,
you know,
this is kind of a crazy chaos,
right?
Well it's,
it's being distanced from like drones.
When you think about the idea,
I mean,
I dunno what percentage of Americans think that drones are fine is,
I don't know what the number is,
but it's way higher than it should.
There's friend,
my friend who were,
I was talking to this week and those words disappointed it didn't care about the
NSA was also talking about how great drones are.
Yeah.
I mean you're talking about the execution of people that don't have a it,
we're not at war with them.
They're not the enemy and they're not.
I mean,
technically these are,
you know,
people in different countries,
there's no war against them and they're being tried and executed on the spot,
not even by a human being.
And we're sitting at home going like,
well,
that's good because we don't put a,
we're not putting American soldiers at harm.
Yeah,
but we're putting our nation.
How would you feel a fucking robot showed up in your country and started killing
your people?
Chinese robots.
Do you think that would start to get people rallied to go attack the United
States?
I mean,
it's going to cost us lives one way or the other.
They're not surgical,
you know?
And he was talking about surgical strikes like drones doing surgical strike them
all four.
I'm like,
do you understand the numbers?
Like if you ever read the numbers,
like even the good spin on the,
the numbers show shocking amounts of civilian casualties.
Weddings,
the good spins.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's bad.
It's bad stuff,
right?
A lot of innocent people,
a lot of accidents,
a lot of people mistaken for the rent,
for the enemy that weren't the enemy.
There's a lot of bad shit that happens when you shoot rockets from flying space.
Ships
now are desensitized to that being an actual killing of a human being because
it's in another country and,
and for the most part people see the whole Middle East is our enemy.
I feel like it could get to a point where it could be real and effective.
I can get to a point where they can have something that's like the size of a
bird that can fly across the world and literally is attracted to the DNA of the
greatest terrorist on earth,
finds him and shoots one through his heart and there's nothing he can do to stop
that.
That's surgical.
And I'm so I would support the fuck out of something like that.
No Sir.
Soldiers have to be involved.
You take a crazy radical and extremist who's a a warmonger.
He take them one of these,
you know,
death to the Great Satan guys.
Take them off the face of the planet.
We don't have to worry about planes flying buildings anymore.
I get that,
but that's not what we're dealing with.
We're dealing with some,
some thing that's not ready yet.
It's like using windows 90 yeah.
You just said planes running into buildings and you're talking about sending
out,
you know,
and that way sort of those are drones.
If you can get a person to do it.
Sure.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
it's very similar,
but those people died,
you know?
That's the thing.
People are like,
we got to take revenge.
Well,
the people that actually did that are dead.
They were on a plane.
They flew up to see they died.
Yeah.
There's something,
there's an investment on that end that I believe in this cause enough that I
will put my life on the line to carry out this killing.
And that sounds like you're very pro nine 11 and it was supporting the
terrorist.
Greg,
it sounds like you're,
you're one of them.
You're either with us or you would.
Then I support nine 10 and let me explain.
I know what you're saying.
You know,
I don't,
I don't respect it.
I think it's a fucking horrible decision,
but it's a much bolder move is what you're saying.
Then then being a guy with a remote control,
well,
you know,
look,
we're the ones that we invented guerrilla warfare here.
I mean the revolutionary war,
not us,
but our,
our four founders,
the fine man that hid behind bushes and shot the stupid British as they walked
in red coats and snare drums up the street.
You know,
we were the first ones to fucking try it out.
Well,
not really.
We were just the first ones to do it in the Western world.
He did it well.
Yeah.
The Mongols had done it much better.
Right?
Thousand years before,
you know,
close to 800 years before whatever the fuck it was.
The,
the idea that these dummies would wear these fucking white and red suits with a
big cross.
We were supposed to shoot
guys got a teapot behind them.
Hard.
It was the idea of this proper way to do war boy.
What a stupid idea.
But I mean,
it goes to what we're talking about right now.
Is it proper to send a drone in or not?
Maybe I am backward by saying like,
this is the,
just the next step in military action is to not involve human beings and by me
saying,
well,
you should have to have a human being killing a human being to make it morally
right.
Maybe that's naive.
I mean obviously like you said,
if we can,
if we can target somebody specifically,
then there's no doubt that that's the way to go.
But I think the further you are physically from the enemy,
the further you are emotionally and easier it is to objectify that person
without giving them due process.
It comes right back to youtube comments.
It's the same thing,
right?
Using a drone and commenting on youtube and being a con kind of the same thing.
You don't have to feel the repercussions.
You don't have to be there and actual shoot the baby in the face because the
baby is standing in front of the terrorist.
You don't have to be there and blow the building up and watch the children crawl
out with no legs.
Right.
You don't have to be there,
but that happens.
It happens whether you like it or not.
There's plenty of videos,
there's plenty of photographs is plenty of real disturbing evidence that people
that were fucked up by drones.
Well,
I'll look at Vietnam.
The war ended because we had news coverage of it for the first time.
We actually had cameras photographing napalm and you know,
children being,
you know,
burned in their homes and all of a sudden there was an outcry that,
uh,
hey,
this is wrong.
We shouldn't be doing this.
It would have gone on a lot longer.
And that is absolutely why George Bush wouldn't let people photograph coffins
during the Iraq war.
They put the actually stopped information,
they stopped photograph.
You could take photographs of the war,
but only favorable photograph.
You couldn't show anybody wounded.
You couldn't show anybody that was doing anything fucked up.
And you couldn't show any bodies that were,
you know,
being shipped back home.
Two mothers and fathers realized that here's where your children die.
Your children died for a lie.
Right?
It shows you,
oh,
weapons of mass destruction.
We thought they were here,
but let's keep sending your kids over.
Yeah.
And then,
and then,
yeah,
the,
the only reporters were embedded,
embedded like you,
here's your fucking tour guide.
He's going to show you what we want you to see.
And there's no report is just like in Vietnam,
they were staying in a hotel downtown,
wandering around and looking at whatever they want,
shooting whatever they want.
And I think they still had to encrypt and send stuff back because they were
trying to stop it.
Uh,
they,
they were going through stuff that was being mailed back.
You gotta remember there's no fucking Internet back then.
They were sending hard pictures back to,
you know,
the Washington Post or wherever and the,
those packages were being looked at.
So they started taking,
um,
the,
negatives and putting them,
hiding them inside of other stuff and shipping them back.
Wow.
That's their way of encrypting.
That's fascinating.
Wow.
That's nuts.
Yeah.
So it's,
it's,
I mean,
what is the moral,
where is that,
what's the high watermark on when,
when you can take a human life,
first of all,
you have to declare war.
I think it's pretty senseless that we can,
that you can continue to kill people without a trial and another country without
declaring war on that place.
You have to,
there has to be an investment that that causes accountability.
Yeah,
they're really does.
There has to be an investment.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's a really good way to put it and know they're also,
you know,
there's this reality of detachment that it's sort of contrary to the very idea
of technology in the first place.
What's what,
what's fascinating about technology and ultimately enriching about technology is
a connection thing.
It's not a detachment thing.
So this is almost like,
like a preliminary stage before it's done.
Right?
Sorta like the model t sucks for racing.
He tried,
tried to take a model t out on a race course.
It's a fucking disaster thing will fly off the side of the road.
The first turn you hit.
Then they figured out somewhere along the line how to make a corvette and then
all of a sudden it's hugging and Graham blom blom going around corners or like,
oh,
they got it better.
Right.
I figured it out.
They got it better.
And that's where we're at when it comes to this with the benefits of this kind
of technology.
I think ultimately the benefits of this technology,
if you look at the trends,
the trends being that it's,
it dissolves the boundaries between people and information that's got to make
more accountability and that's gotta make people more aware of their actions.
Ultimately it's just not there yet.
And so when you have technology that's being used to do the exact opposite
thing,
like a youtube comment or a drone,
like something where you're not,
there's,
there's a disconnect.
If fact you fat can't kill yourself,
clicks and walk out of the house had no repercussions whatsoever.
Wave to your neighbor,
pretend you're a nice guy and no one knows cause you're 69 POC and you to
whatever fuck it is.
Yeah.
There's the,
that's,
that's like that can't keep going on.
It's contrary to the very benefit of the technology itself.
It's the KKK online.
Yeah.
And it's also putting a fucking mask over your hand instead of having the balls
to,
yeah,
it is in a lot of ways.
Yeah.
And it's also,
it's like,
you know it ain't right.
You know,
it's like you're getting away with it.
You getting away with it because it's open,
right.
It's like people that have gotten away with various loopholes that have existed
throughout time that don't exist anymore.
People found holes through it.
They got away with it and now you can't do it anymore.
You used to be able to compete in the Olympics while you're on steroids and then
someone said,
hey,
why did these women look like men?
What the fuck is going on and why are their world records still being held
today?
Do you know that like the eastern bloc women,
they did a lot of track and field records.
It's still can't be broken.
No asterisk on that.
With most of the people that are involved in sports science,
there's a lot of asterix,
but we had Victor Conte on the podcast.
He was the guy from [inaudible].
Do you know what that is?
The Guy,
he's the guy who provided all the various untraceable steroids to all these
professional athletes.
And then it became a big scandal and he actually went up,
wind up going to jail.
But uh,
he's now a car.
A guy who openly criticized is like all the various people that are doing
steroids and shows how they're getting away with it and tries to,
you know,
clean up sports and a lot of ways.
But one of the things that he pointed out was it,
this world records that women made that women can't even touch today.
They can't,
they just can't because they can't be on Anna drawl 60 and
whatever the fuck that,
I mean I always think about it like I'm not a jock and I don't like jocks in
general.
Yeah.
I feel,
I feel like athletes are,
you know,
they're supposed to do the best they can do,
whether it's exercise and nutrition or training.
And if,
I mean you've talked about how there's certain steroids that are not bad for
you,
so shouldn't it just be a part of the sport getting better?
Well,
here's an argument.
One of the arguments is that in order to be to really do your best as a mixed
martial artist,
it's very much like in order to do your best as a cyclist,
you almost can't do it without some form of help.
And then the question becomes,
well what is that form of health?
Well,
the form of health was some athletes can be really good nutrition,
really good supplementation that's legal and uh,
going to a very good sports doctor who can monitor your blood and make sure
you're getting the proper nutrients.
But if you try to do that on the average diet that like a poor person's on,
most likely you're going to short.
Of course there's exceptions to the rule.
Does genetic specimens,
they can eat cheeseburgers and I can run five hours a day and not never have a
problem.
There's people are not created equal
when it comes to keeping it accessible to every
well it's that,
I mean it's,
but I've heard it argued that took tour de France privy example,
you literally cannot do it correctly unless you're on drugs.
That in order to do,
to compete at the world championship levels that we saw Lance Armstrong reach
and all these other people reach you,
your body is actually healthier if you're taking drugs that you have to dope
your blood,
you had to do it without the EPO and the testosterone without adding to your
system.
You're putting a great strain on your system in a point where it might not
really be able to do that.
You might read line your whole shit and break it.
So,
but for people to be able to get into the Tour de France that don't have
sponsors and don't have a,
you know,
an an arsenal of money from past wins,
how do they get to that level to compete?
Well,
it becomes a problem because there's certain things like endurance athletics or
are real.
It's a real issue.
The threshold you endurance threshold.
Some people are born with a higher endurance threshold and there's nothing you
can do about that.
They have larger hearts.
They've,
they processed blood more easily.
Whatever the fuck it is,
whatever it is,
all people are not created equal.
Just like some people don't have a big juicy Dick like yours.
Oh my God,
I just went to the bathroom and enjoyed it again.
So a regular person with a regular deck has to just deal with that in life.
Just like a regular person doesn't have the lungs of a guy like King Velasquez.
Cain,
Alaska is who's the UFC heavyweight champion.
They did his vo Max.
They tested it.
It's like fucking high level triathlete.
He know.
He's Kinda like a 38 beat per minute heart rate.
I mean,
he's a freak.
Great.
So then how do you feel about it?
Do you think there should be absolutely no,
uh,
steroids and drugs?
No Blood doping or you think that with the Tour de France it's okay,
but not with mixed martial arts.
I think that it becomes a real issue with mixed martial arts because it's not
just about winning a race.
It's about beating the fuck out of someone.
And if a guy takes something that's illegal and because of that is able to
perform much better and much longer and do more damage to his opponent,
I'm against it.
But I'm also against,
this is where it gets really tricky.
There's a thing they're doing called testosterone use exemptions where they're
giving people medically approved testosterone injections that are competing.
I'm against that.
I'm against that for two reasons.
One,
because,
um,
I've talked to a,
this guy,
a Dr. Mark Gordon,
who's a traumatic brain injury specialist and he specializes in helping people
with Tbi and um,
and,
and helping them recover from brain injuries.
And one of the things that's damaged in brain injuries is your endocrine system,
your pituitary gland stops producing testosterone correctly and he can fuck with
your hormonal balance.
That can happen with bad concussions.
So then the question becomes,
if someone is 30 years old or even younger and medical testosterone because
they've taken too many blows to the head,
should they be allowed to fight?
That becomes a real issue is are we just sort of putting a bandaid on a much
greater threat to this person's health that
like that might be nature's way of saying,
stop fighting,
dude,
I watched videos today.
You know,
and I don't talk about this too much.
Uh,
because um,
I really didn't fight that long.
I mean,
I fought a lot when I was a kid,
but I didn't really take too many blows to the head until I started kickboxing.
Kickboxing was much more,
I,
I definitely got hit in the head many times as a young man training and
sparring,
but the kickboxing was much more brutal and I used to have pretty significant
headaches when I would lie in bed at night.
And it was one of the main reasons why I was pretty desperate to stop doing it.
I was pretty desperate to like make this choice between standup comedy and
fighting and ultimately fighting one out or comedy rather one out without any
debate whatsoever.
But the idea that I was ruining my brain was really fucking scary to me.
And then you got the,
also the idea that those shots that I took to the head,
which was,
you know,
many,
many rounds of sparring with guys who are better than boxers in me,
many jabs to the face.
Many times my dome got jolted with head kicks,
all that shit was going on.
But nothing compared to what these professionals have to deal with.
And for 10 years and for yeah,
and hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of documented shots to the head in
competition.
Forget about what's going on in training.
You know,
I only had three fights as a kickboxer,
as a taekwondo,
taekwondo,
tournament's,
and karate terms.
I had,
it might have been a hundred,
it was probably way over 50 I don't know how many times I competed,
but that was over a course of like six years.
But for kickboxing it was just three.
And those three were rough,
you know,
it was the,
the,
those,
that feeling of getting,
you know,
fucking punched in the face and seeing stars that has not good for you.
But so there was a part of you that just knew with common sense,
like your body was saying you should not continue to do this,
but there's guys that somehow don't have that,
that governor and their head that says move away from,
it's not just that it's trainers,
trainers want,
like I came,
the guy that I was training with and the gym that I was training with when I was
learning how to box,
it was a very blood and guts,
Boston gym.
I mean these are the guy who was the head coach was a fucking savage and he grew
up with savages and when guys got knocked down in the gym,
they dusted those motherfuckers back off and throw them right back in the ring
again.
And I saw it over and over again.
Guys got slammed on the Chin there,
legs gave out.
They fall flat on their back and then five minutes later they're sparring again.
You're not supposed to do.
You're just not,
not only not supposed to do that.
You're not supposed to spar for months after that.
Not Five minutes later,
not even five days later.
It's supposed to be a long time off.
We give your brain a chance to heal like some shit went down.
Did they know that shit back then?
Okay.
Oh
No.
That's the problem.
They didn't know.
But now we could to see like real up close first of all now because of the
Internet,
because of Twitter and Facebook and the like.
People will share articles with each other.
Like I get way more information now than I've ever gotten in my life and now
being in the position where I am as a,
as an MMA commentator,
people are always sending me things on the dangers of traumatic brain injury,
whether it's MMA or football or even soccer man.
A lot of dudes in more concussions in soccer than football.
Well not just concussions,
just heading the ball.
It's not concussions.
It's the problem.
It's,
it's also the,
the,
the slightly less than concussive impact.
Yeah.
The ones that don't give you a concussion,
but just thumps to the head,
the jarring of your brain.
They're all bad.
Yeah.
I played soccer yesterday.
Every thanksgiving I put together this soccer game for everybody in our
neighborhood.
And it's like yesterday we had 18 on 18 giant field and Vantis and uh,
so it's like a lot of kids.
And it started out when we started out,
the kids were little and we used to split off into an adult game and a kids
game.
And as the adults have gotten older,
all our kids have been in club soccer,
getting better and better.
And now it's really getting to the point where they're as good as we are.
So my son is in the corner.
My,
my son is a captain of his club soccer team.
They were undefeated this year.
He's got a fucking strong leg,
kicks,
a corner kick at me.
I'm in front of the goal.
And I mean,
the thing has got a beeline from a head,
this screams fucking goal.
And all I gotta do is,
but it's coming to my head.
Come in my head last second.
I fucking duct 10 kids started laughing at me for like a minute.
I was like,
something in my head went,
no,
you did.
This is not a good,
that's called smarts.
I signed,
gave me so much shit.
Well,
he's wrong and you're right.
You should want to kick your dad the head with a ball.
That's shit's ridiculous.
Well,
one,
well,
I wanted to bring the subjects I was watching,
so I spent some time today going over these videos.
I'm,
one of them is Meldrick Taylor.
Do you remember Meldrick Taylor?
Yeah,
Olympic gold medalists.
One of the greatest boxers to ever come out of the amateur system.
Amazing fighter.
But I want you to pull up Meldrick Taylor now and then go to the,
the first video that pops up on Youtube.
Meldrick Taylor fought Julio Cesar Chavez,
like one of the greatest Mexican boxers of all time,
and they had this incredible war,
fucking 12 round war where Chavez knocked him down like the last few seconds of
the fight and they stopped the fight.
He was winning the fight.
Up until that moment Chavez has got to him,
but it was a brutal,
brutal beating that he took.
And now when you talked to him,
he's younger than me.
Listen to him talk.
She's interviewing him.
As soon as Brian,
he can barely even hear him all fucked up,
Brian.
I don't know what's going on here.
How about you turned the volume up,
put out the volume on youtube.
What about of the volume on the input?
I'll figure it out.
Okay.
Well it's like with Mohammed Ali,
I mean,
no,
no.
This is way different because he's way,
yeah,
this guy's way,
way younger.
No,
but I think with Molly though,
the mainstream,
and I'm not a huge boxing fan,
but I saw it and you just go like,
wow,
this is fucking sad.
This leads to this.
Well,
and it does,
by the way,
Terry Norris also has it.
Who's another great champion from the 90s and Terry Norris a,
there's a,
a thing that he put out a video.
If you go to Terry Norris today,
you'll get it too.
So is it the video itself that's fucking up?
Yeah,
I'm gonna try a different brand.
It can't be,
I listened to it today.
It might just be the browser.
Let me try a different browser.
HSP.
Brian Terry Norris is another one who was,
uh,
he's my age and I listened to him talk now and it's this massive labor and his
wife is in this interview and she's talking about how he has Parkinson's.
So He's,
his body is taught in lean still,
but it's because his muscles are always stiffening up.
Like his muscles are constantly stiff,
like,
and he can't talk.
He can't form sentences.
You can't understand it.
Did I?
I went to school with this kid.
He got in a bar fight,
punched the wrong way,
landed the wrong way.
And to this day he's a fucking mumbling.
Halfwit wow.
One Punch.
You know,
people think about Barre fight.
Oh,
you're a bar fight.
It was funny last night.
Jim got it.
That's it man.
This kid is like,
he was a promising kid.
Smart.
And then he,
now he's like getting arrested all the time.
He can't,
you know,
he's self medicating and it's fucking 25 years ago.
Well,
it's just like the story that you were talking about before the podcast even
started about the guy would add and he shot himself,
right?
Yeah.
What was that story?
The guy had something he told Jamie.
That's right.
Jamie told it that a guy had,
what did he have?
He had OCD shot himself,
didn't kill himself,
but shout out the part of his head that was fucking with OCD and now he doesn't
have it anymore.
He fixed himself.
Uh,
the human brain.
There was another story that I was telling about a guy who got a head injury and
all sudden became a musical genius.
Yeah.
Never had any musical talent whatsoever.
Had a head injury and then all of a sudden it had this new found thing.
Right.
No,
I've heard of that shit happening with music before.
You know,
it orders,
somehow it orders your brain and you're able to express yourself still.
But you know,
um,
I,
I think that,
uh,
not being hit as a kid is pretty big too.
I think that a lot of kids got beat a lot by their dads.
And I think when your brain is really young,
kids like five,
six years old to get knocked around all the time,
you wonder why kids get fucked up as they're older.
Yeah.
That's also this intense feeling of betrayal or your parents or your,
your dad abuses you like that where your dad is,
this big person hits this little person and hits you hard.
Right.
I have friends that their dad's knocked them out,
dad knocked him out like they had the balls to stand up to their dad.
So the dad punched him in the face and knocked him unconscious.
He imagined like standing over your five year old out cold cause you just
slugged him.
That's a lot of people man.
And that's also a repeating cycle,
just like abuse.
Like sexual abuse tends to a repeating cycle for whatever reason.
The human brain is like very strange and w w the,
the patterns that it follows,
even abusive patterns,
you know?
And there's a few people that can figure it out and break the code.
And that's one of the things that I admire about you
of risk repeating it.
Yeah.
Uh,
one of the things I admire about you is like,
we were like 21,
you just fucking quit drinking.
You're like,
fuck this.
You know,
like,
I know what I'm doing.
I know this is a mass.
I knew my dad.
Fuck this up.
Fuck I'm fucking done.
And you were just done.
Right.
You know,
you were done then you never,
and you just,
you never made a big deal about it.
You're just done.
You know,
when people would ask you if you want to be or you're like,
Nah,
I don't drink,
I can't drink.
But it wasn't like some woe is me.
Hey,
I'm fucking 2000 days sober,
here's my new chip.
All that stupid shit.
It was none of that.
It was just like,
you know,
you just recognize a bad pattern that you weren't going to repeat.
You're not a dummy and you're like,
fuck this.
Well,
I think it's what's difficult with recovery for some people is that,
um,
there's chemical,
and I think what you're talking about is traumatically,
you know,
repeating that cycle.
And I think for me,
I don't know if it was this chemical because I was able to stop without Rehab
and a program and stick with it.
And I think when it's traumatic it's about like anything,
a new habit they say takes 90 days,
you know,
if you can,
and that's a big part about Aa is stopped for 90 days because then you can
change the neurons in your brain to start to feel good about what you're getting
from this new behavior.
It's not just about leaving it behind,
it's like,
wow,
when I don't do that,
I feel all these great things and the reason I don't drink anymore,
it's just that I treasure how lucid I am all the time.
You know,
like last night I met this,
this party and there's like a bunch of people I love that I don't get to see
enough where it's like I would love to spend two hours with each one having a
deep conversation.
And you're only getting like 15 minutes each,
but at least I'm like in it for each.
I'm not like fucking fuzzy and putting my arm around her.
Hey Man.
Yeah,
I don't,
I just know I don't want that.
Yeah.
Well you know,
you recognize when things are positive and beneficial or not and just go that
way.
Go the good way.
Right.
Yeah.
Some people though,
you know,
I,
I definitely agree that the,
the abuse thing is a lot more difficult to overcome.
It seems like whatever these patterns are that get carved into someone's,
someone's personality and brain is that 90 days things up science.
Yeah.
I've heard that again and again at 90 days if you start exercising,
if you quit eating a certain thing that after 90 days,
and it's not that it's physiologically your body is kicking caffeine or whatever
for 90 days,
it's just psychologically that they say that that's about where you do.
You develop a new way of being conditioned to,
to not need that thing as much.
That's fascinating.
And it totally makes sense.
It seems like we were completely creatures of habit and if you could just force
something to become a habit,
then it just becomes your everyday thing.
You figure out how to work this yet.
It's the video.
That's
right.
We tried it on three different browsers and an iPad doesn't work.
We just try a different video of random video and there's interest.
Okay,
well pull up uh,
Terry Norris then or see if there's another version of that video.
Um,
if there's not enough of our version of that video,
pull up Terry Norris today.
Let me find the one that the video and o r r I.
S today.
It's fucking sad dude.
On the show.
This one,
maybe
my husband,
WPC and boxing hall of Famer.
We are together and we have a reality show.
I pause that for a second.
Let me see if I can get this video to work over here.
He's got a reality show,
two time world shit and it'll pick the gold medalist.
This is worked in there.
I don't know.
Listen to us saying that Obama phone game falafel,
that's what's about to say personnel to dilute portion.
But it turns out tomorrow,
but before 12 the scope portion,
the fights,
he'll fight cost [inaudible] power.
Yeah,
that's enough.
Is that a speech impediment or is that no cute drama?
No,
no.
It's just being punched in the head and this what they call pugilistic dementia.
It's just being punched drunk.
They call it punch drunk because when you've been hitting the head so long or so
many times you're,
you sound like you're drunk and you labor over your words like you're drunk.
And I've seen that in fighters.
I've seen that in people that I personally know.
I've seen that from guys that I knew when I was a young man that they were lucid
and smart when I was a kid and they kept fighting when I stopped and I talked to
them today and I see them talking like they're drunk when there stone cold
sober,
this guy.
Are they not intelligent anymore?
They're missing something.
I mean,
they're definitely,
they're definitely cognitively compromised.
Right.
And for anybody to try to protect.
Oh,
he's sharp on the inside.
He just has a hard time.
Can we,
is that why he's telling the same story every five minutes,
right.
No,
this is bullshit.
You're trying to make a positive spin on something.
Maybe he can keep going,
you know,
and he can write books and just can't talk.
But there's other people that don't know where the keys are.
Right.
You know,
there was an article in sports illustrated about Joe Montana and about a Joe,
not Joe Montana.
Uh,
Jim Mcmahon from the
bowls is the bears.
Yeah.
The fuck they are.
Cargo bears.
Remember the last?
Yeah.
The whole,
the whole fucking the Superbowl shuffle.
Shuffle.
That guy fucked.
Yeah.
Like that guy sometimes is standing in the middle of his kitchen.
He doesn't know where he is.
Like he can't remember what he was going to do.
He was about to leave.
He's holding his keys.
He has no idea where he's going.
He's starting his all rap is because he used to,
he used to run too much.
Yeah.
And he used to get his fucking cage rattled.
All of them.
The,
the,
the dude,
uh,
Brett Farve he's talking about he forgot an entire of his daughter
playing soccer.
Like he forgot she played soccer.
Like it's gone.
It's not in his head any more.
You think about all the money you've got and all that,
but you don't have your fucking mind.
I'll give up a leg,
dude.
It's dangerous.
You know Dick though I'd keep my Dick Harlow.
Yeah,
we do.
Sweet Dick.
Put it up on the screen Brian and beat your Dick all day and look at it.
No,
no.
Pugilistic dementia.
Think straight.
Um,
but the thing about my penis is that it doesn't bruise.
And I believe me,
I've put some beatings on it.
If people want to buy your,
uh,
your Special Gregory,
tell him where to get it and what it's called.
I believe you go to Amazon
[inaudible] dot com but I know if you got to fits dog.com,
there's a link on there to pick it up.
It's uh,
you know,
I don't know what it cost,
but I think it's,
I think it's pretty good.
And then
it's hilarious.
Thank you.
Enjoyed it.
Thanks for listening,
by the way.
I appreciate a lot of comics.
Say,
you know,
they ain't gotta check it out and they never fucking do.
Yeah,
those guys are cunts.
Shitheads any favor?
Edo.
And if I can promote again,
December five through seven Boston Laugh Boston,
I'm coming up as a great new room.
And uh,
I'm going to do a podcast the first night,
Thursday,
the fifth live podcast at the club piss.
[inaudible] live on stage.
That's what it's called.
Life on stage.
Oh,
life.
Life,
Not Live life on stage.
Uh,
I got it off of Amazon because I switched over to a so you can hear it.
Oh,
nice.
So you know,
I don't want to give any of it away.
Go buy it.
Fucks.
That's good.
It's excellent.
And where are you at?
Uh,
what's the,
what's the next day you got,
uh,
this Boston Laugh Boston and then after that in January I'm coming to Minnesota.
Fort Lauderdale,
Chicago.
No,
I'm doing the big one in the mall.
Oh,
okay,
cool.
And,
uh,
I get a,
I dunno,
a bunch of dates fits dog.com and then obviously the podcast fits dog radio that
you just came on recently.
I was fucking great.
I was off that night.
I felt bad that I don't know what it was.
You came as some,
you know,
some nights you come in and you just not just not,
they crazy.
It was great.
All right,
good.
I had a wonderful time.
All right.
I don't even use the word wonderful.
Um,
so,
uh,
Boston is when,
what was the date?
Uh,
December five,
three seven and I will be performing a,
yeah,
on the fifth.
Again,
I'm still looking for that.
Writes a comedian to come down and be on the live podcast.
I got,
I got a few names out.
Good googly Mowgli.
Alright,
thanks to stamps.com use the code word j r e and get your bonus $110 bonus
offer.
Thanks also to onnit.com it's o.
N N.
I.
T.
A.
We got a black Friday sale that's going on for another three days,
six hours and 33 minutes.
As of this podcast,
it expires December 2nd at 11:59 PM Pacific Standard Time.
Um,
use a code name,
Rogan on any other time and save 10% off any and all supplements.
We will be back next week.
We got the dude was,
uh,
working for marine world,
marine land,
whatever the fuck it is.
It's gonna give us the inside scoop of what cons they are,
their animals.
This shouldn't be fucking fascinating cause they tried to sue this guy.
He's the guy that was a walrus trainers is a big,
big whole thing he'll be on next week.
Uh,
lots of other people,
lots of other fun.
And uh,
that's it.
We'll see you guys soon.
Have a wonderful weekend and big kiss from breakfast Hammons.
Yeah.